den verheerenden Krieg in der Ukraine
finanziert Energie im weitesten Sinne
und Energiekosten das ist heute auch
Thema im Bundestag es ist ja
haushaltswoche und heute wird der Etat
des Bundesministeriums für Wirtschaft
und Klimaschutz besprochen dem Robert
Habeck vorsteht und er hat schärfer hat
das Ganze für uns im Blick
vielen Dank Tina Dauser und herzlich
willkommen auf der Plenarsaal Ebene des
Deutschen Bundestags ja in der Tat wir
können das was wir nachher ab 9 Uhr im
Plenum erleben auch noch mal kurz
verbinden mit dem was wir gestern schon
erlebt haben im Plenum in der
Generaldebatte als das Thema
Energieversorgung Energiesicherheit und
Energiekosten ja auch schon ein großes
Thema gewesen ist dem Rededuell unter
anderem zwischen Oppositionsführer märz
und regierungsschef Scholz da ging es ja
auch schon ziemlich munter zur Sache und
wir werden dieses ganze hier genauso
munter noch ein klein wenig vertiefen
und deswegen freue ich mich dass heute
morgen bei uns sind Julia Verlinden
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und Jens
Spahn ist bei uns stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der cdu/csu-fraktion hier
im Deutschen Bundestag guten Morgen Frau
Verlinden ich habe zwei allgemeine
Einstiegsfrage was ist eigentlich so
dramatisch daran oder was wäre so
dramatisch daran zu sagen wenn wir auf
die Energieversorgung gucken und wie wir
die in dieser schwierigen Lage
bewältigen wir lassen die Atom Netzwerke
einen begrenzten Zeitraum noch mal
weiterlaufen bleiben aber beim
Atomausstieg die Debatte wäre abgeräumt
sie hätten in der Koalition
wahrscheinlich deutlich weniger Stress
und das gäbe eine na sagen wir mal eine
klare Perspektive für sagt man maximal
zwei Jahre die Atomkraft ist eine
hochrisiko-technologie und deswegen
haben unter anderem auch Jens Spahn und
alle anderen damals 2011 den Ausstieg
erneut beschlossen und das ist auch
richtig so wir müssen raus aus dieser
gefährlichen Energieerzeugung und es
machten Unterschied ob wir im Augenblick
alles daran setzen dafür zu sorgen dass
die Netze stabil bleiben und dafür
leistet eben die Atomkraft kaum ein
Beitrag das heißt was wir im Augenblick
tun müssen ist und genau anzuschauen was
getan werden muss um eben auch die Last
gut zu verteilen und vor allem muss man
auch noch mal dazu sagen was diesen
Stresstest angeht nur unter ganz
bestimmten schlimmen Annahmen werden wir
überhaupt nur in eine Krisensituation
kommen also die Versorgungssicherheit
ist gewährleistet in Deutschland und es
ist nicht damit zu rechnen dass wir ein
Strommangel erleiden müssen also
insofern ist es ein guter Weg zu sagen
wir tun alles um da sicher jetzt auch
durch den Winter zu kommen und die
Atomkraft ist nun mal keine sichere
Technologie wir gucken uns ein zwei
Punkte in der gleichen Anschluss noch
mal ran ein Serie auch eine ähnliche
Einstiegsfrage was wäre so dramatisch
daran auch mal zu sagen okay wir haben
für den Atomausstieg gestimmt wir haben
für den Kohleausstieg gestimmt und wir
haben in den vergangenen Jahren einfach
viel zu wenig für die erneuerbaren
Energien gemacht höre ich nicht so
häufig aus ihrem Rhein nun zuerst der
Schärf die erneuerbaren Energien haben
sich verzehnfacht in den letzten Jahren
in ihrem Anteil an der Energieerzeugung
ich akzeptiere das noch mehr passieren
soll aber es ist viel passiert aber wir
sind ja jetzt in einer anderen wir sind
jetzt in einer anderen Lage wir haben
Krieg in Europa wir haben Krisenlage und
wir haben ja jeden Tag Strom Mangel
Höchstpreise an den Strom und Gasmärkten
entstehen weil Mangel ist so ist der
Markt in Deutschland und in Europa der
Strombedarf ist riesig und in einer
solchen Krise in einer solchen
Ausnahmesituation muss man doch müssen
wir doch in der Lage sein noch mal zu
schauen sind wir hier gerade auf dem
richtigen Weg wir sollten alle Formen
der Energieerzeugung jede Kilowattstunde
die geht nutzen dazu gehört Biogas dazu
gehören Kohlekraftwerke dazu gehören
sichere die deutschen Kernkraftwerke
sind nur wirklich sicher und verlässlich
sichere Kernkraftwerke und hier geht es
darum die Laufzeit für die nächsten zwei
drei Winter zu verlängern es geht nicht
darum den Ausstieg ein Ausstieg zu
machen sondern in der Krisenlage
Stromproduktion für Deutschland zu
sichern und das scheint mir doch eine
richtige wichtige Entscheidung die
leider nicht getroffen wird ganz kurz
zurück zu meiner Frage alles richtig
gemacht in den letzten drei vier
Legislaturperioden das habe ich nicht
gesagt das war auch im Übrigen nicht
Ihre Frage wir haben in Deutschland
gemeinsam ist übrigens nicht nur ein
Thema der Union weil ich immer die
letzten 16 Jahre höre was aufzuarbeiten
wie wir in diese große Abhängigkeit von
Russland von russischer Energie geraten
konnten nordstream wurde von Rot-Grün
Schröder Fischer Trittin entschieden wir
sind diesem Weg ja auch weiter gegangen
wir sind aus Kerne und Kohleenergie auf
dem ausstiegsweg und jeder wusste steht
übrigens auch im Koalitionsvertrag der
Ampel aus Dezember noch drin Gas ist
dann die Brücke hin zu den erneuerbaren
auch nach dem Koalitionsvertrag der
Ampel hätten wir mehr Gaskraftwerke und
damit mehr russisches Gas gebraucht also
ich akzeptiere unseren Teil aber ich
habe schon den Eindruck das waren
breiter gesellschaftlicher Konsens sie
haben ihm gesagt Frau verlinken die
Energie Sicherheit sei gewährleistet die
benetzsicherheit da gibt es überhaupt
gar keine Probleme jetzt mit Betreiber
haben das nach dem Ergebnis des
Stresstest anders gesagt wir haben
gesagt sie hätten sicherheitshalber dann
doch die Atomenergie noch dabei
ich muss da korrigieren ist ich habe
gesagt dass es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist
dass wir in ein Krisenszenario kommen wo
die Netzstabilität nicht gewährleistet
ist es hängt von ganz vielen
verschiedenen Dingen ab vorher nicht das
ist ja das ist richtig und genau
deswegen ist ja auch der Vorschlag von
Robert Habeck dass wir die drei im
Augenblick noch am Netz befindlichen
Atomkraftwerke in eine Notfallreserve
schieben dass wir sie wie geplant am
31.12 abschalten wie es der Atomausstieg
vorsieht und dann für den Fall der Fälle
das dass diese
unwahrscheinliche Lage eintritt dass sie
doch noch gebraucht werden sollten
dann können wir sie wieder ans Netz
nehmen das ist der Vorschlag der gerade
auf dem Tisch liegt wir reden über sechs
Prozent Anteil am Strommix glaube ich
maximal warum muss es unbedingt
Atomstrom sein Herr Spahn warum nicht
alternative Energien erneuerbare
Energien weiter ausbauen nun wir stehen
vor einem Winter vor einem
wahrscheinlich sehr harten Winter für
schließen sie auch nicht doch das ist
jetzt schon eine wettertechnisch meine
ich naja ist Winter ist jedenfalls
kälter als Sommer das glaube ich können
wir immer noch festhalten und deswegen
werden wir Strom und Gas mehr brauchen
noch als im Sommer wir haben jetzt schon
Höchstpreise ich habe auch diesen
Stresstest nicht verstanden wir haben
jeden Tag Stresstest Familien Handwerker
Pflegeheime wissen nicht mehr wie Sie
Ihre Stromrechnung bezahlen sollen und
deswegen sind sechs Prozent der
Stromerzeugung kein gamechanger die
ändern nicht alles aber ein wichtiger
Beitrag wie Kohlekraftwerke wie Biogas
der Wirtschaftsminister sagt jeden Tag
jede Kilowattstunde zählt damit
begründet der duschtipps
einsparverordnung wenn aber jede
Kilowattstunde zählt zählt auch jede aus
dem Kernkraftwerk an den Preisen würde
es nichts ändern habe ich doch doch das
ist eine dieser mehrere dieser dieser
Geschichten die gerade erzählt werden
natürlich würde es was ändern weil umso
mehr deswegen wird ja auch zum Beispiel
die Kohle zurück ans Netz geholt umso
mehr andere Energieformen wir ans Netz
holen desto öfter entsteht der
Strompreis wird ja jede Viertelstunde
gemacht und so desto öfter entsteht eine
Situation eine Ausbildung wo Gas keine
Rolle spielt klar es wird auch Stunden
geben Viertelstunden geben wo der Gas
das Gaskraftwerk den Preis immer noch
bestimmt aber umso mehr Energie wir
vorher mit anderen auch mit Erneuerbaren
aber auch Kernkraftwerken erzeugen desto
weniger oft und damit wird der
Durchschnittspreis sinken das ist so an
den Märkten da haben sie mit dem Kopf
geschüttelt genau weil wir haben jetzt
gerade am Wochenende hat der
Koalitionsausschuss getagt und
zahlreiche Maßnahmen verabredet um die
Preise auch auf dem Strommarkt zu
stabilisieren beziehungsweise zu senken
so weit es geht dazu werden gerade auch
europäische Gespräche geführt weil das
wichtig ist wir haben einen europäischen
Strommarkt und da macht es keinen Sinn
wenn Deutschland Alleingänge macht
zumindest sollten wir es versuchen
sollten wir es versuchen gemeinsam zu
lösen und wir haben zahlreiche Maßnahmen
auch verabredet in der Ampel umzusetzen
um auch Menschen zu entlasten bei den
hohen Energiekosten und ich finde
wichtig an der Stelle noch mal darauf
hinzuweisen was wir da alles tun was wir
insbesondere auch tun um mehr
erneuerbare Energien an Kontakt zu
bringen und da gibt es natürlich jetzt
sehr viel aufzuholen von den letzten
Jahren wo der Ausbau leider nicht so gut
vorangegangen ist und das müssen wir
jetzt alles mit Hochdruck quasi
Korrigieren von der Vorgängerregierung
und da sind wir dran und wir haben
zusätzlich auch finde ich noch den sie
haben das Thema Energiesparen
angesprochen eine Option die wirklich
sehr viel bringt und vor allen Dingen
auch bei den Preisen einen großen
Unterschied macht ist als für mich
wirklich noch mal wichtig zu betonen
dass wir sehr sehr viel Geld im
Augenblick aufwenden um Menschen dabei
zu unterstützen Häuser energetisch zu
sanieren denn das ist doch die Ursache
des Problems das ist doch die Ursache
aber das passiert ja schon seit Monaten
dass die Nachfrage dazu steigt ja die
Nachfrage nach dem energetischer
Gebäudesanierung ja die macht aber ein
riesen Unterschied und deswegen ist es
auch gut dass wir das Problem an der
Wurzel packen denn genau das hat uns ja
in diese ab nicht nur die Abhängigkeit
von russischen Energieimporten hat uns
eine schwierige Lage gebracht sondern
auch
die Gebäude seit Jahren Jahrzehnten mehr
Energie verbrauchen als nötig und das
heißt insbesondere die alten
ineffizienten Gebäude sorgen dafür dass
Menschen hohe Heizkosten haben und da
sind große Potenziale und da müssen wir
jetzt dran müssen
wie viel günstiger wird meine
Kilowattstunde Strom wenn diese
Atomkraftwerke tatsächlich weiterlaufen
würden in dem Umfang wie sie ist das
vorstellen das kann man so natürlich auf
den Cent Preis nicht sagen aber eines
ist ihm klar es Marktwirtschaft umso
größer das Angebot desto geringer der
Preis und Sie haben ja zurecht gesagt
stimmig absolut in aus Überzeugung zu
keine Alleingänge europäisch abgestimmt
alle alle unsere europäischen
Nachbarländer bitten uns die
Kernkraftwerke am Netz zu lassen weil es
ja nicht nur um die deutsche nationale
Netzstabilität geht sondern auch um die
europäische alle sagen bitte produziert
so viel Strom wie es geht wir brauchen
ihn in Europa und Deutschland geht da
ein unsolidarischen Alleingang bei
diesem Thema habt ihr doch noch mal
einen Punkt weil
weiß bestimmt werden ja weiterhin die
Gaskraftwerke auch wenn auch wenn die
Atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen wird ja über
die Gaskraftwerke der Preis bestimmt für
den Strom das ist nein
seine mehr aber wir nur dann wenn die
Gaskraftwerke benötigt werden wir haben
ja nicht den ganzen Tag zu jeder
Viertelstunde denselben Strombedarf in
Deutschland sondern der steigt und singt
der ist mittags höher als Mitternacht
und umso öfter Momente entstehen wo die
Gaskraftwerke nicht gebraucht werden
weil die anderen so viel produzieren
wird eben auch dann nicht der Strom da
gesetzt zumal die Gaskraftwerke die
wärmekopplung machen die gebraucht
werden also für die Wärme auch gar nicht
so mit in den Preis mit einberechnet
werden also es ist nicht ganz so einfach
auch beim Strompreis wie uns das gerade
gelegentlich erzählt wird
möglicherweise sind das ein paar ganz
wenige Minuten im Monat der die Frage
ist ja immer die Atomkraftwerke
produzieren Grundlaststrom und die
Gaskraftwerke werden flexibel eingesetzt
insofern ist es einfach auch schwer
vergleichbar aber trotzdem trotzdem ist
nein die Gaskraftwerke laufen nicht
durch haben sie eben selber gesagt im
Moment müssen Gaskraftwerke so viel Gas
verstrom wie nie zuvor selten zuvor das
ist doch ich bin in der Krise verstrom
Vegas jeden Tag ich will nur einfach
darauf hinweisen sie haben halt eine
andere Perspektive darauf ob wir eine
hochrisikotechnologie einsetzen oder ob
wir alle anderen Optionen die uns zur
Verfügung stehen mehr erneuerbare
Energien auch aus den jetzt schon
stehenden Anlagen rausholen das tun wir
wir haben jetzt ein
energiesicherheitsgesetz eine Reform auf
dem Weg gebracht nein das ist jetzt das
ist das weiß ich nicht 20 30 Gesetz was
wir im Energiebereich jetzt beschließen
werden in den nächsten Wochen also wir
haben zahlreiche Rahmenbedingungen
verbessert um mehr erneuerbare Energien
ans Netz zu kriegen und auch aus den
laufenden Anlagen rauszuholen Biomasse
haben sie angesprochen auch das ist auf
den Weg gebracht und es geht darum dass
wir zusätzlich
energieeffizienzpotenziale nutzen und
all das sind Dinge die wir tun und die
auch erfolgreich ein Beitrag leisten und
in der Summe
ausreichen werden um die Situation im
Winter zu gewährleisten und falls der
unwahrscheinlich Fall eintritt das doch
nicht dann ist der Vorschlag der Reserve
auf dem Tisch was ist Ihr Modell
Strompreise dauerhaft zu stabilisieren
oder sogar zu senken erstmal so viel
Angebot wie möglich also alles ans Netz
was geht zum zweiten die Rücklagen der
EEG des eeg-kontos zu nutzen um
Netzentgelte und Stromsteuer für das
nächste Jahr zu senken oder ganz
aufzuheben und zum dritten verlässlich
ein Strom ein gasgrundbedarf für jeden
Haushalt der ist geplant aber keiner
weiß im Moment wann der startet zu
welchem Preis keiner kann Plan für den
Winter und das ist ein Problem die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Line
hat gestern diverse Vorschläge gemacht
welche halten sie für realistisch was
die Umsetzung angeht innerhalb der
nächsten Zeit
Deckelung gaspreisdeckel für russische
Gasimporte Reduzierung von
in Stromverbrauch in Zeiten hoher
Nachfrage also das Lastmanagement ist
ein ganz wichtiger Teil und da das
passiert ja auch schon auf dem Markt
also insofern ist das auf jeden Fall
etwas was wir auch
verstärkt einsetzen werden aber
zusätzlich finde ich eben auch wichtig
dass es gut ist das Europa sich
gemeinsam auch verabredet hat deutlich
Gas auch einzusparen Julia verlinken
vielen Dank auch Jens Spahn vielen Dank
dass Sie hier gewesen sind ich bin ein
bisschen irritiert wie sie gemerkt haben
weil ich irgendwie von drin schon
Applaus gehört habe aber die Uhren hier
im in der Lobby zeigen noch eine Minute
von neun ich würde sagen sie verlassen
mich ganz fix damit sie im Plenarsaal
sind irgendwie also wir haben es
versucht irgendwie und da ist ja immer
noch vorne und es klingelt auch jetzt
erst im Hintergrund also etwas
ungewöhnliche Situation vielen Dank dass
sie da waren und dann bis zum nächsten
Mal und wir schauen direkt in den
Plenarsaal rein meine Damen und Herren
muss ich mich jetzt immer selber ein
bisschen orientieren wie da im Moment
die Lage ist ob mit
Bundestagspräsidentin schon angekommen
ist gebe den kurzen Ausblick auf das was
hier heute
Vormittag bis um die Mittagszeit
passiert es wird ja nicht nur über den
Etat über das Haushaltsgesetz 2023
geredet beginnend mit dem Etat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers gleich um 9
es wird auch dann um den Etat des
Bundesgesundheitsministers gehen und es
geht vor allem auch um das
Infektionsschutzgesetz bzw die
Änderungen daran und jetzt höre ich im
Hintergrund den Gong waren wir gar nicht
so schlecht mit der Zeit und haben uns
hier ein bisschen irritieren lassen von
Geräuschen aus dem Plenarsaal und da ich
den Gong gehört habe und da ich auch die
Bundestagspräsidentin auf dem Weg zu
ihrem Platz sehe gebe ich jetzt auch
einfach mal ein
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
einen schönen guten Morgen
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung begrüße
ich zunächst einen neuen Kollegen Nils
Gründer hat für den ausgeschiedenen
Kollegen Dr HC Thomas Sattelberger die
Mitgliedschaft im deutschen Bundestag
erworben herzlich willkommen und auf
gute Zusammenarbeit
dann gab es in der parlamentarischen
Sommerpause einige besonders
erwähnenswerte Geburtstage so haben die
Kollegen Norbert Maria Altenkamp und
Stefan Keuter jeweils ihren 50
Geburtstag
gefeiert herzlichen Glückwunsch
die Kollegen Dr Klaus Wiener und Detlef
Seif jeweils den 60 Geburtstag gefeiert
herzlichen Glückwunsch
[Applaus]
und der Kollege der hier gerade neben
mir sitzt
rainer semeth hat den 65 Geburtstag
gefeiert herzlichen Glückwunsch
[Applaus]
und der Kollege Axel Schäfer seinen 70
geburtstag
herzlichen Glückwunsch
[Applaus]
das kommentiere ich nicht habe es auch
Gott sei Dank nicht gehört dann müssen
wir noch ein eine Wahl durchführen in
den Beirat zur Auswahl von Themen für
die
sonderpostwärtzeichen ohne Zuschlag beim
Bundesministerium für der Finanzen es
ist der sogenannte Programmbeirat soll
auf Vorschlag der Fraktion der FDP der
Abgeordnete Reinhard Huben als
Nachfolger für den Abgeordneten till
Mansmann als ordentliches Mitglied
gewählt werden sind Sie damit
einverstanden
dass sieht so aus das ist der Fall damit
ist der Kollege Huben gewählt
ich komme schließlich zur Tagesordnung
interfraktionell wurde vereinbart die
Tagesordnung um die in der Zusatzpunkte
Liste aufgeführten Punkte zu erweitern
es handelt sich dabei um mehrere Anträge
die ohne Debatte behandelt werden sollen
sind sie damit auch einverstanden ich
sehe keinen Widerspruch dann ist das
auch so beschlossen wir setzen jetzt die
Haushaltsberatungen fort für die heutige
Aussprache haben wir am Dienstag eine
Redezeit von insgesamt neun Stunden und
39 Minuten beschlossen und wir beginnen
die heutigen Beratung mit dem
Geschäftsbereich des Bundesministeriums
für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz und das
Wort hat zu Beginn für die
Bundesregierung der Minister dr Robert
Habeck
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Herren und
Damen guten Morgen eigentlich haben wir
besseres und Wichtigeres zu tun als
übereinander zu reden die Wirklichkeit
fordert unsere volle Konzentration und
Aufmerksamkeit dennoch möchte ich einmal
sagen dass der Sound der
selbstkritiklosigkeit den ich hier
gestern gehört habe eine Antwort
erfordert lieber Herr Merz 16 Jahre lang
hat die Union dieses langen kreiert und
viele Bundesländer 16 Jahre
energiepolitisches versagen und wir
räumen in wenigen Monaten auf was sie in
16 Jahren verbockt verhindert und
zerstört haben sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
und das tun wir mit einigen Erfolg seit
einer Woche gibt es kein Gas aus
Russland die Speicher füllen sich weiter
nach einem kurzen Ausschlag in der Börse
ist der Preis noch immer hoch und zu
hoch aber nicht explodiert seit einer
Woche sind wir unabhängig von russischem
Gas wegen der konsequenten und
vorausschauenden Handlungsfähigkeit
dieser Regierung und dieser Koalition
gestern hat Frankreich nachdem es immer
Abnehmerland war erstmals Gas nach
Deutschland geredet Erfolg von
diplomatischen Anstrengungen und
Bemühungen es war ein Testbetrieb
dennoch gleichzeitig ein historischer
dann ist verstärkt die europäische
Solidarität sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
dass wir da stehen wo wir sind liegt
daran dass diese Regierung von Tag eins
an einen konsequenten Kurs gefahren hat
und wusste wohin sie will und weiß was
die Not des Tages erfordert nämlich ein
bekämpfen der aktuellen Krise bei
Beibehalten der strukturellen
notwendigen Veränderungen die dieses
Land in die Zukunft führen wird deswegen
haben wir immer alle Maßnahmen mit der
notwendigen Transformation kombiniert
die Energieeffizienz der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren war immer integraler
Bestandteil unserer Politik und dass die
Union in dieser Krise in dieser
Wirtschaftskrise ernsthaft dagegen klagt
dass die notwendigen Investitionen in
erneuerbare Energien in Energieeffizienz
in Wasserstoff hochlauft und auch noch
in die Robustheit der Unternehmen
verfassungswidrig sein soll das ist
ökonomischer Wahnsinn meine Damen und
Herren wie wollen Sie denn den
Unternehmen wie wollen Sie denn den
Unternehmen erklären dass sie am Ende in
dieser Situation wo wir einen
nachfrageschock haben keine staatlichen
Unterstützung mehr bekommen es zeigt
westfossilen geisteskind sie noch immer
sind
ich habe manchmal den Eindruck dass sie
überhaupt noch nicht verstanden haben
welchen Ausmaß die Herausforderungen der
Zeit das hat erfordern welche
Anstrengungen wir nehmen müssen welche
Umstellung auch in der Art wie wir
Politik denken notwendig sind
stattdessen immer nur weiter das
Opposition diese oppositionsklänge und
möchte gerne Wirtschaftspolitik sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
was ist das wichtigste
das Wichtigste ist dass wir die
preismanipulation durch Putin beenden
wir können auf Dauer nicht gegen die
hohen Preise anzupensionieren deswegen
müssen wir jetzt und werden wir das
energiemarkdesign so ändern dass die
günstigen Kosten an die Verbraucher
weitergegeben werden und die hohen
Kosten zwar noch den Marktmechanismus
geben aber nicht mehr durchgereicht
werden morgen ist der energieministerrat
in Brüssel die Vorschläge der Kommission
liegen vor man sieht wie gut Europa
arbeiten kann und sie gehen sehr in die
Richtung die auch wir vorgeschlagen
haben da sind wir auf einem guten Weg
aber auch das muss man aussprechen wir
machen etwas in wenigen Wochen was
normalerweise Jahre wahrscheinlich zwei
Jahre Beratung gebraucht hätte wir gehen
an das stromagdesign rein und wir halten
uns eine Option offen wenn das nicht
sofort und solide gelingt dann werden
wir über eine abschöpfungsabgabe die
Gewinne kassieren und den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern zurückgeben
wir werden
auch
wir werden auch beim Gaspreis etwas
machen müssen wenngleich komplizierter
aber es ist nicht richtig dass wir uns
in eine Situation hineinbegeben wo wir
es für jeden Preis einkaufen wir werden
auch dort Mechanismen entfinden und den
Gaspreis herunterbringen wir stoppen
damit den Abschluss des Geldes ins
europäische oder ins globale Ausland und
wir stoppen es am stärksten
perspektivisch indem wir uns nicht mehr
von russischen Energien sondern von den
fossilen Energien insgesamt losmachen
wer das verkennt wer das verkennt
verkennt in welcher Phase wir uns
eigentlich befinden bis wir die Preise
runter bekommen haben und das wird
sicherlich ein bisschen dauern bis wir
die Preise runter bekommen haben werden
wir den Unternehmen jede Hilfe zukommen
lassen wir werden einen breiten
Rettungsschirm aufspannen und wir werden
in breit auf Spannung so dass vor allem
die kleinen und und die die KMU's unter
diesem Rettungsschirm runterfallen
können was heißt das konkret wir werden
das Programm dass wir jetzt aufgestellt
haben für die Industrie das
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm öffnen
für KMU's wir werden damit die
handelsbezogenheit als Kriterium die
handelsbezogenheit als Kriterium
aufgeben wir werden es branchenöffnen
gestalten aber an Kriterien natürlich
festhalten Kriterien kann beispielsweise
der Energiekostenanteil an Produkt oder
am Umsatz sein es wird zeitlich
befristet sein weil wir einen anderen
Instrumenten arbeiten nämlich die Preise
stoppen und so die Unternehmen und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlasten es kann
also keine Dauer Subvention sein aber
dieses Programm wird aufgelegt werden
und es wird der deutschen Wirtschaft den
Weg in diese neue Zukunft erleichtern
beziehungsweise dafür sorgen dass wir
ihnen gehen können wir werden wir werden
die deutschen Unternehmen und dem
deutschen Mittelstand schützen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren nicht alle
Unternehmen leiden unter den hohen
Energiekosten wir haben einen
nachfrageschock das Geld in den
Haushalten wird knapp und deswegen
werden wir im weiteren Maßnahmen
wirtschaftspolitische wie vor einem
strukturelle Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
dass die Menschen in Deutschland genug
Geld haben auch zu konsumieren und so
die Unternehmen stützen können bzw
Unternehmen ebenfalls geschützt werden
die nicht nur alleine über die in die
energieintensive
Produktionsweise von dem Programm wie
eben skizziert erfasst werden und
fünftens werden wir im Oktober einen
Mechanismus auflegen wo Gas gegen Geld
den Gasverbrauch runterbringt und die
Unternehmen die dann in der Produktion
etwas zurückfahren schützt und
finanziell entschädigt sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Putins Angriff zielt
auch auf unserer Wirtschaftssystem es
wird immer gesagt es ist die schwerste
Energiekrise seit 1973 das ist nicht
richtig diese Energiekrise ist weit
komplexer die Aufgaben sind weit größer
und deswegen müssen wir das was im
Normalfall gut funktioniert jetzt
hinterfragen und ändern wir müssen das
Marktdesign am Strommarkt ändern wir
müssen die fiskalpolitischen Rahmen neu
denken wir müssen die Geschwindigkeit
und die Entschlossenheit mit der
politische Entscheidung fällen über
hinterfragen und verändern wie wir es
getan haben und wir sollten vielleicht
auch überdenken in welcher Rolle
Opposition und Regierung sich manchmal
befinden sehr gerne Damen und Herren
vielen Dank
mit Kritik an der Union an wie er sagt
fehlender Selbstkritik bezüglich der
Energiepolitik der vergangenen Jahre hat
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck die
Debatte über seinen Etat für 2023
eröffnet Energie in allen Facetten wird
beherrschendes Thema dieser Aussprache
sein auch in der ersten Rede aus der
Opposition und da steht schon bereit
Jens Spahn einer der stellvertretenden
Vorsitzenden der cdu/csu-fraktion
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Jens Spahn
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen jede Kilowattstunde zählt das
ist ihr Mantra in dieser Krise Herr
Minister damit begründen sie duschtipps
und einsparverordnung denn wenn in
dieser Krise aber jede Kilowattstunde
zählt dann müssen wir schon fragen ob
dieses Mantra dieses Motto auch für ihre
Regierung und ihr Handeln gilt denn wenn
jede Kilowattstunde zählt dann zählt
auch jede Form jede Form der möglichen
Energieerzeugung die hier in Deutschland
möglich ist und da tun sie nicht
da tun sie nicht was geht sie nutzen das
Potenzial von Biomasse Biogas nicht sie
haben unseren Antrag im Juli hier
abgelehnt im Sommer haben sie gesagt
jetzt wollen sie es doch tun ein
konkreten regelungsvorschlag haben wir
bis jetzt nicht wir nutzen die
Erneuerbaren klimaneutralen
Möglichkeiten beim Biogas seit Monaten
nicht und das ist Ihr Versäumnis
Kohle Kohle wir haben hier im März
gesagt Kohlekraftwerke aus der Reserve
hochfahren um beim Gas die Verstromung
runterzufahren da haben sie noch gelacht
im Juli haben Sie dann die Gesetze
geändert um es tun zu wollen muss man ja
sagen mittlerweile zweieinhalb Monate
später sind zwei in Worten zwei
Kohlekraftwerke nur neu am Netz wegen
ihrer bürokratischen Vorgaben weil sie
zu spät gehandelt haben wenn jede
Kilowattstunde zählt dann hätten diese
Kohlekraftwerke schon längst am Netz
sein müssen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und dann Kernkraft sechs Monate Debatte
mit verschleppen Falschaussagen Streit
sie hätten am Montagabend einen
Befreiungsschlag machen können für Klima
Schutz und Versorgungssicherheit
stattdessen haben sie das Chaos
perfektioniert sie handeln gegen die
Empfehlung des Stresstests der
ausdrücklich sagt die drei
Kernkraftwerke im streckbetrieb zu
lassen sie haben uns immer gesagt das
ginge nicht Personal man müsste Gesetze
ändern Sicherheitsanforderungen jetzt
machen sie genau das sie ändern das
Gesetz sie halten das Personal sie
stellen die Sicherheit sicher nur sie
produzieren keinen Strom das ist das
Problem an ihrer Lösung
Familien Handwerker Pflegeheime haben
jeden Tag Stresstest seit Monaten die
können nämlich ihre Stromrechnung nicht
mehr bezahlen und Stromrechnung
Strompreise sind deswegen hoch weil das
Angebot in Europa zu niedrig ist und das
heißt jedes Kraftwerk muss ans Netz aber
Herr Minister
das Kernkraftwerk in Lingen das ist nur
wirklich die Spitze des ihrsinns sie
wollen das ist der Vorschlag
ölkraftwerke auf Schiffen
zu teuren Preisen anmieten um im
Norddeutschland die Netzstabilität zu
gewährleisten anstatt das
klimaneutrale Kernkraftwerken zu lassen
wer hier den Geist von fossilen Energien
hat das können wir da gerne mal
diskutieren nur weil ihre
nur weil ihre Wahlkämpfer in
Niedersachsen bei bei Atomen auf die
Plakate geklebt haben lassen sie als
grüner klimaminister lieber ölkraftwerke
auf Schiffen laufen anstatt ein sicheres
Kernkraftwerk und ich finde das ist
Harakiri in der Lage in der wir aktuell
sind
und Gaspreise das ist die Lehrstelle
auch ihres entlastungspaketes beim
drängsten Thema von 20 Millionen
deutschen und vielen Unternehmen nichts
keine Lösung stattdessen die gasumlage
wie sagte jemand zu treffend Deutschland
ist wenn die Regierung plant per Umlage
auch Konzerne mit Milliardengewinne zu
subventionieren dafür dann die
Mehrwertsteuer gesenkt wird um von der
Umlage betroffene Verbraucher zu
entlasten um dann über eine
übergewinnsteuer die Unternehmen die
profitieren dann wieder zu belasten
stoppen Sie diese chaosumlage stoppen
Sie diesen Irrsinn stimmen sie nachher
unserem Antrag zu das aufzuheben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und geben Sie vor allem den Menschen
Sicherheit für diesen Winter bei Gas und
bei Strom
strompreisbremse keiner weiß wann in
welcher Höhe beim Gas gar kein Angebot
für jeden Haushalt verlässlich einen
Grundbedarf 75% des vorjahresverbrauches
definieren und Sicherheit geben für
diesen Winter das bräuchten wir dringend
denn frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Deutschland steht ein
schwerer Winter ins Haus Deutschland und
die Deutschen werden ärmer jeden Tag
wegen hoher Gas und Strompreise wir
sollten alles tun soziale Not zu lindern
Familien Handwerkern der Wirtschaft in
dieser schwierigen Zeit zu helfen wir
haben wir haben wir haben ihn wir haben
ihn mehrfach
wir haben ihn mehr haben ihnen mehrfach
Angeboten jetzt warten Sie doch mal wir
haben ihnen mehrfach Angeboten Herr
Minister in dieser schweren Zeit mit in
die Verantwortung zu gehen
Kompromisse zu suchen das haben sie
abgelehnt sie sind ihren Weg gegangen
und das finde ich haben sie gerade auch
in der Art noch mal sehr sehr deutlich
gemacht das ist ihr gutes Recht sie
haben die Mehrheit aber damit ist eins
auch klar in diesem Winter sind
Höchstpreise bei Strom und Gas in diesem
Winter ist die Unsicherheit von
Millionen Menschen im Land ist jeder
Strom und gasausfall ist jede Insolvenz
und jede Betriebsaufgabe dann auch ihre
Verantwortung reden sie sich nicht mit
16 Jahren raus es geht hier um ihr
Krisenmanagement seit sechs Monaten
darum geht es
Deutschland wird die deutschen bräuchten
in dieser Lage nichts Deutschland und
die deutschen bräuchten in dieser Lage
nichts mehr als Zuversicht und
Zusammenhalt
Deutschland und den deutschen bräuchten
in dieser Lage nichts mehr als
Zuversicht und Zusammenhalt und Sie
müssen sich die Frage stellen ob die
Entscheidungen die sie treffen und die
Art wie sie Politik machen wirklich
geeignet sind Zuversicht und
Zusammenhalt im Land zu stärken mein
Eindruck ist das nicht
Jens Spahn mit deutlichen Worten aus
seiner Perspektive in Richtung
Regierungsbank und in Richtung
ampelchorlation das war ein bisschen
absehbar wie diese Debatte hier
verlaufen wird zum Etat des
Wirtschaftsministers aber sie merken das
Thema Energie ist tatsächlich das
beherrschende hier heute nächster Redner
wird Matthias Miersch sein
stellvertretendervorsitzender der
SPD-Fraktion und mit großem Interesse
wird übrigens auch der Redebeitrag von
Sahra Wagenknecht aus der aus der
Linksfraktion erwartet die ist in Kürze
schon dran erstmal Matthias Mörsch frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Herr Spahn sie haben eben gewünscht dass
wir auf sie hören dass sie mit
Verantwortung übernehmen können sie
haben viele Jahre hier Verantwortung
getragen
und sicherlich war nicht alles schlecht
in der großen Koalition aber das Thema
Energiepolitik wenn dort eine Ampel die
letzten 16 Jahre regiert hätte wären wir
jetzt tatsächlich zukunftsfest liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn sie und wenn sie auch jetzt
noch in die Verantwortung gehen wollen
dann sage ich ihnen ich bin heilfroh
dass sie es nicht sind nun ist das
energiepolitisch bei ihnen nicht so sie
haben einen anderen Fachbereich gehabt
deswegen nehme ich Ihnen das nicht so
ganz übel aber hier so dicke Sprüche zu
machen und dann Vorschläge zu machen die
dieses Land bereits im Frühjahr in die
Knie gezwungen hätte da finde ich ein
gewisse Selbstreflexion wäre angesagt
und Herr Merz als Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzender der gestern große
Worte findet sie haben hier
im März deswegen kann man sich gut
merken der Merkspruch sie haben hier im
März ein Gas embargo gefordert wir wären
jetzt keine es wäre keine Möglichkeit
gewesen sie Speicher zu füllen die
Preise wären vorher schon explodiert
wenn wir Ihnen die Verantwortung gegeben
hätten
das ist die Wahrheit und damit müssen
sie sich auseinandersetzen und nicht ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister kritisieren
der Tag und Nacht versucht auch
Versäumnisse ihrer Politik wegzumachen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber richtig ist
wir leben in Zeiten die diese
Gesellschaft auch vor große
Herausforderungen stellt und wir wissen
gestern wieder einmal dass es Gruppen in
diesem Haus gibt die sagen es muss
diesem Volk schlecht gehen weil wir dann
politisch Profit daraus ziehen wollen
und ich bin Ihnen dankbar Herr Merz dass
sie gestern noch mal bekannt haben alle
demokratischen Parteien müssen hier
zusammenhalten und dieser Populismus
darf nicht durchgehen
aber
wenn man diesen
Populismus bekämpfen will
dann muss man sehr aufpassen bei der
Argumentation die man hier als
Opposition vorbringt denn die Menschen
haben zu Recht finde ich die Erwartung
dass wir hier streiten um den besten Weg
aber wir müssen auch um belastbare
Lösungen streiten und ich will ihnen das
an dieser Stelle sagen so wie sie mit
dem Thema Atom in den letzten Monaten
umgegangen sind ist es für mich reiner
Populismus die Atomkraft als Lösung in
dieser Phase zu sehen ist eine Sackgasse
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
warum haben wir denn das Problem weil
augenblicklich 32 der 56 Atomkraftwerke
in Frankreich nicht am Netz sind liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und warum haben wir ein Problem im Süden
Deutschlands weil ihre Regierung in
Bayern alles unterlassen hat was ein
Thema erneuerbare notwendig gewesen wäre
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn sie suggerieren durch die
Zuschaltung und Laufzeitverlängerung von
drei Atomkraftwerken würde sich beim
Preis etwas ändern dann machen sie den
Menschen etwas vor atomkraft ist nicht
preismindern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es gibt es gibt nur einen Weg
augenblicklich die Preisspirale in den
Griff zu bekommen und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat zu Recht
darauf hingewiesen es muss ins System
eingegriffen werden und deswegen ist es
richtig was am Samstag beschlossen
worden ist
und wenn sie sagen
ja wir machen das mit dem Stresstest und
dann muss es noch eine
Laufzeitverlängerung geben dann will ich
Ihnen schon sagen es ist elf Jahre her
elf Jahre die Bundeskanzlerin Merkel an
dieser Stelle gesagt in Fukushima haben
wir zur Kenntnis nehmen müssen dass
selbst in einem Hochtechnologieland wie
Japan die Risiken der Kernkraft nicht
sicher beherrscht werden können daraus
ist eine riesen Diskussion entstanden
und wir haben alle in diesem Haus den
Ausstiegsbeschluss einvernehmlich
gefasst weil wir wussten dass Atomkraft
keine Lösung ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aber ich unterstelle Ihnen sie haben es
aus machttaktischen Gründen gemacht sie
sind nie davon überzeugt gewesen und
deswegen kommt jetzt sofort wieder eine
Scheinlösung die sie hier präsentieren
weil sie parallel dazu die letzten Jahre
im alles auch getan haben um den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien zu verhindern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn sie suggerieren dass sie durch
die Laufzeitverlängerung
Versorgungssicherheit sicherstellen
könnten dann sage ich ihnen setzen sie
wieder aufs falsche Pferd was wir
brauchen ist in der Tat die reservekraft
die wir jetzt bei Kohle zur Verfügung
stellen auch das Schöpfen von Biogas etc
aber den maximalen Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien in den nächsten
Monaten liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und und das sage ich für die
SPD-Fraktion auch hier im Bereich der
Wärme muss das was die Regierung
vorgedacht hat beim Thema Strompreis
auch Realität werden auch beim Thema
Gast auch beim Thema Wärme brauchen wir
systemische Eingriffe in dem Markt wir
können nicht gegen subventionieren wenn
Preise explodieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und wir sind sicher dass die
eingesetzte Kommission denn nichts ist
trivial aber in den nächsten Wochen
belastbare Vorschläge diesen Parlament
macht damit wir auch Wärme in den Griff
bekommen und für verbrauchen und
Verbraucher und Unternehmen Sicherheit
in diesem elementaren Bereich
gewährleisten können liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
aber wir wissen auch dass alles besser
ist wenn wir es europäisch machen und
deswegen lieber Robert Habeck alles Gute
für morgen die Europäische Union das
will ich hier betonen steht vor einer
großen Belastungsprobe es muss geliefert
werden wenn nicht geliefert wird müssen
wir hier nationalstaatlich in diesen
Elementen Vorgehen das steht für uns als
sozialdemokratischer Fraktion fest
Energie ist Daseinsvorsorge wir brauchen
einen starken Staat der den Menschen
jetzt Sicherheit gibt vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Matthias mir stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der SPD-Fraktion nennt den
Versuch eine mögliche Energie Lücke mit
Atomenergie zu schließen eine Sackgasse
und eine Scheinlösung ist ist hier viel
Vergangenheitsbewältigung auch in dieser
Debatte nächster Redner der einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
afd-fraktion Live Erik Holm
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Herr Minister sie haben von der
fehlenden Selbstkritik der Union
gesprochen dass wir uns völlig einig 16
Jahre lang haben sie an diesem Murks
mitgewirkt aber ich vermisse bei Ihnen
auch um ein kleines bisschen
Selbstreflexion im Angesicht des Murks
den Sie hier noch schlimmer betreiben in
dieser ampelregierung die verkorkste und
unsoziale gasumlage die Abschaltung
moderner Kernkraftwerke das unsinnige
Insolvenz Geplapper bei Maischberger die
letzten Tage haben noch klar gezeigt
dieser Minister und diese Regierung sie
können das einfach nicht wir werden
regiert von energiepolitischen
Geisterfahrern
selbst jetzt im Angesicht von
Preisexplosionen und dramatischen
Knappheiten bleiben Sie weiter auf der
Gegend Fahrbahn und wollen den
Energiewende Wahnsinn noch weiter
treiben während sie funktionierende
Kraftwerke abschalten das kann man auch
wirklich niemandem erklären was sind die
für Traumtänzer unterwegs
machen sie die Augen auf
Millionen Bürger haben Angst ihre
Rechnung für Strom und Gas bald nicht
mehr bezahlen zu können immer mehr
Unternehmen gehen in die Insolvenz ein
Anstieg wird erwartet für Oktober von
einem Drittel sagt aus Leibniz-Institut
hagle Görtz waren die ersten Vorboten
gestern dr Schneider in meiner Heimat
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern steckt fast die
Hälfte der Bäckereien schon in
finanziellen Schwierigkeiten wegen der
explodierenden Preise und sie erklären
den im Fernsehen Herr Minister dass sie
gar nicht Insolvenz müssten sondern ja
mal vorübergehend die Produktion
einstellen könnten das wirkt nicht nur
schräg sondern kommt als hohen an bei
Unternehmen die tagtäglich um ihre
Existenz kämpfen
man muss sich das ja mal vorstellen
Unternehmen und Ihre Mitarbeiter wissen
kaum noch wie es weitergehen soll und
sie wollen die sichersten und modernsten
Kernkraftwerke der Welt abschalten die
zur Senkung des Strompreises hätten
beitragen können mehr Angebot bedeutet
geringere Preise es wäre so einfach
gewesen sie hätten einfach diese
Ankündigung am Montag machen können
Laufzeitverlängerung und sofort wäre der
Future Strompreis fürs nächste Jahr
gefallen das wäre schnelle Hilfe für die
Bürger gewesen und für die Unternehmen
und sie verweigern diese Hilfe da
betreiben sie immer mehr Bürger und
Unternehmen in existenzielle Not man
muss es klar sagen die Preistreiber die
sitzen hier vorne auf der Regierungsbank
unsere Nachbarländer bauen ihre
Kapazitäten aus wir bauen sie ab was ist
daran solidarische Minister das ist doch
keine Solidarität das ist das Gegenteil
wir sind die energieparasiten dieses
Europas das ist schlimm peinlich
stattdessen setzen sie auf eine
Entlastungspaket das allein die Symptome
bekämpft und wieder viele außen vor
lässt die Unternehmen die von der
Mehrwertsteuersenkung bei der gasumlage
gar nichts haben zum Beispiel viele
fleißige die noch jeden Tag zur Arbeit
fahren für wenig Geld aber nichts von
ihren Zuschüssen haben weil sie eben
noch arbeiten gehen das ist nicht
gerecht und was ist mit den Menschen auf
dem Land den haben sie drei Monate einen
trostplässlich hingegeben Tankrabatt ist
schon wieder vorbei warum eigentlich das
war eine sinnvolle Maßnahme wir müssen
runter von den Energiesteuern dass das
einzige was der Staat an dieser Stelle
machen kann um die Inflation einzudämmen
und den Bürgern mehr Geld in der Tasche
zu lassen diese energiesteuersenkung
beim Tanken sie muss kommen sie muss
bleiben dauerhaft es kommt nichts von
ihnen
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen die
richtigen Entscheidungen treffen die
sind jetzt zu treffen die Kernkraftwerke
müssen weiterlaufen und die drei die vom
Netz genommen wurden im letzten Jahr
müssen wieder angefahren werden das
brauchen wir jetzt wir brauchen auch
keine vorschnellen Sanktionen die nur
uns selber schaden und wir brauchen
keine Steuern und Abgaben auf Sprit auf
Gas und Strom die den Menschen kein Geld
mehr in der Tasche lassen runter mit den
Energiesteuern das kann der Staat jetzt
tun das muss er tun ihr Weg ihr Weg
führt geradewegs in die Katastrophe wenn
Sie den weitergeht übrigens den Bäcker
letzter Satz die Bäcker in
Norddeutschland die Bäcker in
Norddeutschland gehen heute auf die
Straße und sagen bei uns gehen bald die
Lichter aus und wenn sie so weitermachen
dann wird es in Deutschland nicht nur
symbolisch sondern wirklich zappenduster
vielen Dank
der Bundestag berät und diskutiert in
erster Lesung über den Etat des
Bundesministeriums für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz und habe ich garantiert
nicht alle Debatten zum Etat des
Wirtschaftsministeriums gesehen aber ich
wage mal die These das hier ist eine der
lebendigsten und ein bisschen auch
aufgeregtesten die wir heute haben
Karsten klein ist der nächste Redner er
ist ob man im Haushaltsausschuss und
kommt aus der FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Stabilität
der Gesellschaft der soziale Frieden die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung und der
Wohlstand sind durch die Inflation
gefährdet Inflation sorgt für
Unsicherheit steigende Kosten gefährdet
unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und damit
auch die Arbeitsplätze jetzt dieses
außer Frage dass die originäre Aufgabe
zur Preisentwicklung zur
preissteigerungsbekämpfung die EZB hat
die Europäische Zentralbank aber jetzt
sind wir keine Zuschauer auch wenn wir
natürlich der Meinung sind dass die EZB
viel zu zarker viel zu langsam reagiert
hat aber deshalb müssen wir auf der
politischen Bühne trotzdem die
Bekämpfung der Inflation flankieren und
das tun die Herr Minister durch zwei
Maßnahmen das eine ist die
Schuldenbremse und das andere ist die
kalte Progression die Schuldenbremse
sorgt dafür dass wir keine expandie
expansive Ausgabenpolitik haben denn es
wäre fatal wenn der Staat die Nachfrage
nach knappen Gütern auch noch anheizt
ist die Schuldenbremse ein wichtiges
Instrument zur Inflationsbekämpfung
und die Bekämpfung der kalten
Progression die führt dazu dass die
Lohnerhöhung auch bei den Bürgerinnen
und Bürger bei den Menschen ankommt
statt beim Staat und sie verhindert dass
es zu einer lungenpreisspirale kommt und
deshalb Herr Minister brauchen wir für
die Inflationsbekämpfung einer klaren
Kurs und auch eine klare Unterstützung
des Wirtschaftsministers weil die
Inflation so eine große Gefahr für die
Wirtschaft darstellt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
zweite Thema weil ich ansprechen will
ist natürlich die Energieversorgung
Energiesicherheit das Energie überhaupt
zur Verfügung steht das Vergessen ja
manche und auch die Bezahlbarkeit der
Energie und weil es in Deutschland in
der Diskussion ja so ein bisschen in
Vergessenheit gerät der Ausgangspunkt
für die Energieproblematik die wir haben
ist der verbrecherische Krieg von
Vladimir Putin in der Ukraine und das
ist das Wladimir Putin Energie als Waffe
gegen unsere Freiheit demokratische
Gesellschaft einsetzt es ist nicht so
dass die Bundesregierung hier wie man
der ein oder andere behauptet die Preise
irgendwie anfangen würde sondern der
Grund dafür sitzt in Moskau
nichtsdestotrotz hat die Bundesregierung
und die sie tragenden Fraktion ja ein
ganzer Anzahl von Maßnahmen auf dem Weg
gebracht um die Versorgungssicherheit
sicherzustellen um die Preisentwicklung
abzudämpfen bei der
Versorgungssicherheit will ich in der
Kürze nur auf die lng-terminals eingehen
die und die nächsten zehn Jahren 2,7
Milliarden Euro kosten werden ohne dass
wir es ermöglicht haben für 15
Milliarden Euro Gas zu beschaffen das in
unsere garsp eingelagert werden kann und
wir werden in den Haushaltsberatungen
Herr Minister auch dafür sorgen tragen
dass der Speicher der für Bayern
zuständig ist aber in Österreich sitzt
auch ein Einspeisung einer Einspeisung
erfährt aber
wir müssen natürlich weiterhin die
Preise im Blick haben Herr Minister und
deshalb ist es umso wichtiger dass die
jetzt beschlossene Strompreis Bremse am
Wochenende auch schnell umgesetzt wird
denn wir wollen dass diese negative
EEG-Umlage die Entlastung bei dem
Haushalten und bei den kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen bei dem Bäcker und
Metzger auch ankommen weil wir die eben
in dieser Krise nicht vergessen und uns
wichtig sind
aber dazu Herr Minister gehört aus dass
wir Druck aus dem System insgesamt
nehmen wir verstromen immer noch zu viel
Gas wir erzeugen zu viel Strom aus Gas
und deshalb müssen wir das substituieren
durch mehr Kohle und durch mehr
Atomkraft eine Reservebetrieb in den am
Anfang des nächsten Jahres ist zu wenig
wir brauchen ein Weiterbetrieb dieser
Realität müssen Sie sich stellen
und natürlich neben den kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen
haben wir auch den Blick auf die großen
und energieintensiven Unternehmen dafür
haben wir ja ein großes Paket auch
geschnürt mit 4 Milliarden Euro im
Haushalt um diese Unternehmen zu
unterstützen jetzt steht es außer Frage
und deshalb hätte ich schon ein bisschen
mehr Demut auch von der Union erwartet
sie haben ja sehr große Baustellen
übernommen von ihrem Vorgänger in
jeglichen Bereich große
Herausforderungen daueraufgaben
Klimawandel Energiewende
fachkräftesicherungen auch im Bereich
der Raumfahrt die großen Posten
finanziell auch in ihrem Etat indem wir
in der letzten vier Jahren eine
schlafwagenpolitik erlebt haben wir
haben
bundesrechnungshofberichte in denen klar
drinsteht dass bei der Wirksamkeit der
Einsetzung von Steuermitteln und sie
haben erhebliche Steuermittel jetzt auch
wieder zur Verfügung mit 13 Milliarden
Euro 1,7 Milliarden Euro mehr als in
2022 das bei diesem Einsatz der
Steuermittel nicht wirksam vorgegangen
wird nicht koordiniert vorgegangen wird
das hat ihr Vorgänger Ihnen als große
Baustelle überlassen aber ich erwarte
auch von Ihnen Herr Minister dass sie
diese System in ihrem Haus abstellen
denn letztendlich haben die BürgerInnen
und Bürgerinnen ein Anrecht darauf dass
wir natürlich die energiesicherung die
Energieversorgung sicherstellen aber
dass wir auch mit den Steuermitteln am
Ende wirksam und zielgerichtet vorgehen
und diese Ausgaben und dafür werden wir
in den Haushaltsberatungen sicher noch
einiges zu tun haben vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Carsten klein war das ob man in der
FDP-Fraktion im
Haushaltsausschuss und wie schon vorhin
mal angekündigt mit einem etwas größeren
Interesse erwartet Sahra Wagenknecht aus
der Linksfraktion
und das größere Interesse bezog sich auf
die eigenen Reihen vor allem ihre
eigenen Reihen
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren in Deutschland bahnt sich eine
soziale und wirtschaftliche Katastrophe
an Millionen Menschen haben Angst vor
der Zukunft vor explodierenden
Lebenshaltungskosten wo
horrorabrechnungen und immer mehr auch
um ihren Arbeitsplatz und auch wenn es
sich noch nicht bis ins
Wirtschaftsministerium herumgesprochen
hat in Schlüsselindustrien werden
Betriebe reihenweise schließen schreibt
das Handelsblatt denn Herr Habeck in der
Wirtschaft ist das leider nicht so wie
in der Politik ein Minister der nichts
mehr liefert muss leider tatsächlich
keine Insolvenz anmelden sie sind das
beste Beispiel dafür
aber ein Unternehmen ein Unternehmen das
wegen der hohen Preise nichts mehr
verkaufen kann das verschwindet vom
Markt und das heißt eben schlicht im
Klartext wenn wir die Energiepreis
Explosion nicht stoppen dann wird die
deutsche Industrie mit ihrem starken
Mittelstand bald nur noch ein Erinnerung
an die guten alten Zeiten sein und die
hohen Energiepreise viel höher als in
vielen anderen europäischen Ländern die
sind doch nicht vom Himmel gefallen die
sind doch das Ergebnis von Politik sie
sind zum einen das Ergebnis ihrer
völligen rückgratlosigkeit gegenüber den
absahnern und krisenprofiteuren die
Mineralölkonzerne werden in diesem Jahr
in Deutschland 38 Milliarden Euro mehr
Gewinne machen als im Schnitt der
letzten Jahre die Stromerzeuger sogar 50
Milliarden Geld das den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern jeden Tag aus der Tasche gezogen
wird andere Länder haben dieses
Marktversagen längst mit preisdeckeln
oder wenigstens mit übergewinn-steuern
darauf reagiert frankreich hat den
Anstieg des Strompreises auf vier
Prozent begrenzt da sind sie nicht erst
nach Brüssel gefahren und haben lange
Verhandlungen geführt ein Liter Sprit
kostet rund 40 Cent in Frankreich
weniger als bei uns und der Beitrag des
hochkompetenten deutschen
Wirtschaftsministers zu Energiekrise er
lässt sich von den
energielobbyisten ein Gesetz zu einer
gasumlage schreiben dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger die Familien und Unternehmen
die sowieso schon leiden zusätzlich zur
Kasse bitten also da muss man wirklich
sagen auf so ein Einfall muss man
erstmal kommen wir haben wirklich die
dümmste Regierung in Europa wenn man
sich das anguckt
nur aber nicht nur weil sie zu Feige
sind sich mit dem Krisen Gewinnern
anzulegen das größte Problem das größte
Problem ist ihre grandiose Idee einen
beispiellosen Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
unseren wichtigsten Energielieferanten
vom Zaun zu brechen ja natürlich ist
zurück in der Ukraine ein Verbrechen
natürlich ist der Krieg in der Ukraine
ein Verbrechen aber die Vorstellung die
Vorstellung dass wir Putin dadurch
bestrafen dass wir Millionen Familien in
Deutschland in die Armut stürzen und
dass wir unsere Industrie zerstören
während
gastron-rekordgewinne macht ja wie
bescheuert ist das denn
preiswerte Energie ist die wichtigste
Existenzbedingung unserer Industrie
und wo haben Sie denn Ersatz aufgetan
habe bei amerikanischen
fracking-gasanbietern die aktuell 200
Millionen Euro gewinnen mit jedem
einzelnen Tanker machen klar so kann man
die gassprecher auch füllen aber den
Ruinen von Familien und Mittelständlern
die diese Mondpreise am Ende bezahlen
müssen den werden sie damit nicht
aufhalten und es fängt doch schon an ich
meine dass der Gaspreis dass der
Gasverbrauch der Industrie umfasst ein
fünfte eingebrochen ist das liegt doch
nicht an plötzlichen Effizienzgewinnen
das liegt doch daran dass die Produktion
schon jetzt dramatisch zurückgeht und
bevorzugtes Ziel von
Produktionsverlagerungen ist übrigens
neuerdings wieder die USA weil der
Gaspreis in Deutschland inzwischen acht
Mal so hoch ist wie in Übersee make
America great again tolle Strategie für
eine deutsche Regierung
der Hauptgeschäftsführer des DRK geht
davon aus dass Deutschland bei
Fortsetzung der jetzigen Strategie in
wenigen Jahren 20 bis 30 Prozent
ärmer sein wird ja ob es uns gefällt
oder nicht wenn wir ein Industrieland
bleiben wollen dann brauchen wir
russische Rohstoffe und leider auf
absehbare Zeit auch noch russische
Energie und deshalb schluss mit den
fatalen Wirtschaftssanktionen verhandeln
wir in Russland mit Russland über eine
Wiederaufnahme der Gaslieferung wir sind
nicht unabhängig wie machen sich doch
uns und uns etwas vor und lieber Herr
Habeck es mag ja sein dass ihnen auch
egal ist was ihre deutschen Wähler
denken aber sie haben nicht das Recht
Millionen Menschen die sie mehrheitlich
nicht gewählt haben ihren bescheidenen
Wohlstand und ihre Zukunft zu zerstören
und deshalb treten sie zurück denn ihre
Laufzeit Verlängerung die führt mit
Sicherheit zum Super-GAU der deutschen
Wirtschaft dankeschön
mit einer Rücktrittsforderung an
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck endet
die Rede von Sahra Wagenknecht aus der
Linksfraktion die sich deutschlandführer
ein Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Zitat unseren
wichtigsten Energielieferanten diese
Perspektive hat sie hier im Plenum
einigermaßen exklusiv Felix bannaschak
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Lobbyistin Sahra Wagenknecht in dieser
Rede reden lassen wollen ich sage mein
aller Verbundenheit dass man eine dumme
Idee eine richtig richtig schlechte Idee
Herr Spahn
ersparen sie haben gerade
sechs Monate mit 16 Jahren verglichen
und ich übersetze das meine gleiche
Einheit 192 Monate hat die
unionsgeführte Regierung alles dafür
getan den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren zu
verschleppen den Ausbau der Stromnetze
zu verstärken insbesondere bei ihnen in
Bayern der Dobrindt 192 verlorene Monate
und das bis heute fünf Minuten hatten
sie zur Verfügung kein Wort zum Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren kein Wort zum Ausbau
der Stromnetze für die
versorgungssicherung das ist ihre
Politik und Nordrhein-Westfalen in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen haben wir
stundenlang diskutiert weil sie jedes
Windkraftwerk verhindern wollten weil
sie jedes Solarpanel verhindern wollten
mit Rücksicht auf die Wahlkreise ich
habe folgende these meine Damen und
Herren wenn in dieser Debatte nur noch
Menschen reden zum Thema Atom die bereit
sind in ihrem Wahlkreis ergebnisoffen
nach einem nuklearen Endlager zu suchen
ist diese Debatte in fünf Minuten zu
Ende Herr banatschak
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage von
Herrn Ernst aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
sie haben das Wort
herzlichen Dank dass Sie die Frage
zulassen
das erste Bemerkung ich komme nicht
darum in dem Moment wo man hier den
Versuch unternimmt das zu tun was er
habe gesagt nämlich uns drum zu kümmern
dass er mehr Energie her kriegen dass
man tatsächlich mehr gasher kriegen dass
wir ölen Sie das ist Interesse Putins
die sind Putin Leute also diese Form der
Auseinandersetzung tut mir leid diese
Form der Auseinandersetzung ich weiß
nicht ob das hier Stil ist ich finde
diese diesem Hause eigentlich
unangemessen und nun die zweite Frage
die zweite Frage ist wir haben nun
mehrfach erlebt dass Vertreter der
Koalition darauf hinweisen dass 16 Jahre
in der falsche Politik betrieben worden
ist das wissen wir inzwischen aber auch
sie haben so oft genug gesagt was sie
aber schuldig bleiben ist wie sie denn
die gegenwärtige Krise nun eigentlich
wirklich bewältigen wollen wir wissen
wir
da könnt ihr euch aufregen wie ihr wollt
ich habe den Eindruck über Ankündigungen
wir wollen wir werden kommen doch
überhaupt nicht hinaus wir haben bis
jetzt keine Lösung zum Beispiel für
Schwedt sie haben keine Lösung für das
was uns im Winter blüht sie haben keine
Lösung wie wir genug Energie herkriegen
und im selben Moment im selben Moment
lehnen sie aber eine Möglichkeit ab wo
er auch nicht wissen wie sie endet aber
man kann doch zum Mittel miteinander
reden und fragen wir kriegen wir denn
mehr Gas her und mehr Öl das könnte man
doch mal machen und wenn Sie das
Ablehnen dann kann ich sagen dann stimmt
natürlich das dass ihnen andere
Interessen als wie die die Bürger und
die Industrie in diesem Lande haben
wichtiger sind als das was sie
eigentlich wirklich machen das ist
wirklich ein Problem
[Applaus]
der Herr Ernst ich habe zwar bei dem was
Sie gesagt haben das Fragezeichen nicht
gehört aber ich will trotzdem gern
antworten das spricht ja Bände für ihre
Fraktion er spricht der Bänder für ihre
Fraktion auch Herr Dr Bartsch dass sie
dazu klatschen das ausgerechnet die
beiden hier sprechen Sahra Wagenknecht
und Klaus Ernst wir entgegen der
Fraktionslinie muss man ja sagen die
Öffnung von 192 fordern und damit das
zentrale sanktionsargument gegen den
Kriegsverbrecher Wladimir Putin außer
Kraft setzen wollen und dass sie
und das seht ihr diese Täter opferumkehr
betreiben und Wladimir Putin und
Russland quasi zum angriffsopfer eines
westlichen Wirtschaftskrieges
stilisieren wollen obwohl Wladimir Putin
nicht nur den Krieg in die Ukraine
sondern gegen Deutschland gegen Europa
und gegen den Rest der Welt führt mit
Energie mit hungerskrisen und so viel
mehr das ist beschämend und das sagt
alles zu dem was sie in dieser Debatte
zu sagen haben
kommen wir
kommen wir zurück zur Union Herr Merz
ist jetzt
Herr Merz ist leider nicht mehr da hat
bestimmt andere Termine Herr März hat ja
völlig richtig schon im Juli gesagt wir
müssen uns auf Wohlstandsverluste
einstellen wenn wir Frieden und Freiheit
gegen unter anderem das was dort gesagt
wurde Verteidiger völlig richtig aber
Herr Merz bleibt leider die zwei
zentralen Antworten schuldig die sich
aus dieser Analyse ergeben nämlich wie
wollen wir diesen Wohlstandsverlust
sozialgerecht verteilen das ist die
sozialpolitische Frage die wir mit
diesem Entlastungspaket seit dem
Wochenende angehen und die zweite die
zweite und dies mindestens genauso
wichtig dass die ökonomische Frage wie
wir diesen Wohlstandsverlust begrenzen
wollen und diese Bundesregierung will
und sie wird den Wohlstandsverlust
begrenzen trotz enorme Herausforderungen
und das hat Robert habe gerade
überzeugend dargestellt
wir haben in dieser debatsche schon am
Dienstag viel über Inflation gehört
unbestritten eine große Gefahr aber die
zweite große Gefahr die laut das ist
doch eine Rezession eine Rezession mit
Abschwung mit Arbeitslosigkeit und mit
Bedrohung für ganze Wirtschaftsbranchen
und deswegen ist es richtig dass die
unternehmenshilfen ausgeweitet werden
dass das Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm
für kleine und für mittlere Unternehmen
ausgeweitet wird dass wir den Spitzen
Ausgleich bei Strom und Energie
verlängern und damit 9000 Unternehmen
stabilisieren das ist die kurzfristige
Antwort auf die Wirtschaft und
energiepolitischen Herausforderungen die
sich hier stellen herr Scholz hat
gestern gesagt wir lösen die Probleme
über vor andere sie direkt erkannt haben
da wäre ich ein bisschen vorsichtig aber
wir haben sie immerhin erkannt wir gehen
Sie an und Sie können leider nur dagegen
opponieren ohne einen eigenen Vorschlag
zu haben dass es ziemlich bedauerlich
aber meine Damen und Herren hinter den
kurzfristigen Herausforderungen vor
denen wir stehen stehenden noch viel
größere und deswegen ist es wichtig bei
allem was wir tun um beispielsweise
lng-terminals jetzt schneller ans Netz
zu bringen neue fossile Infrastrukturen
ja zu schaffen dass wir gleichzeitig den
Blick für die Zukunft nicht verlieren
dass wir die großen
transformationsherausforderungen vor
denen wir sowieso schon stehen und die
jetzt ja nicht kleiner geworden sind
intensiv angehen Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
Ausbau der elektrolysekapazitäten damit
wir bald grünen Wasserstoff zur
Verfügung haben damit an der
direktreduktionsanlage von arsenormittal
in Hamburg die jetzt wegen der hohen
Produktionskosten vom Netz gehen wird
vielleicht bald schon CO2-neutral Stahl
produziert werden kann in diesem
Haushalt und im
klima-betrag für Energieeffizienz
vorgesehen ein Rekordbetrag für den
Ausbau einer klimaneutralen
wasserstoffinfrastruktur ein
Rekordbetrag beispielsweise auch für das
zentrale Innovationsprogramm Mittelstand
alles was sie immer gefordert und selbst
nie umgesetzt haben das ist die Politik
dieser Regierung nur kurzfristig die
notlindern langfristig die
Herausforderung angehen vielen Dank
felix bannaschak war das aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen nächster
Redner in dieser sehr munteren Debatte
ist Andreas Jung da kommt das ja
Unionsfraktion und ist dort Sprecher für
Klimaschutz und Energie
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Minister sie haben in
ihrer Rede in kritischen Blick zurück
angemahnt dazu will ich eine Bemerkung
machen wir haben in der
corona-pandemie eine Lehre aus
vorangegangenen Krisen gezogen und diese
Lehre war in der Krisenbewältigung darf
nie wieder der Klimaschutz hinten
angestellt werden nie wieder dafür zu
sein dass wir über die Bewältigung der
einen Krise die andere Krise die
Klimakrise aus dem Blick verliert und
deshalb haben wir gleichzeitig in
Stabilisierung und Entlastung in
Zukunftstechnologien in Klimaschutz
investiert wir haben alles
zusammengebracht und das ist unsere
Erwartung an sie und das ist unser
Befund das ist in dieser Krise eben
nicht gemacht wird sie stellen den
Klimaschutz in dieser Krise hinten an
bei der Energiesicherheit sind wir nicht
so weit wie sie und Olaf Scholz gestern
darstellen wollten es ist nicht geritzt
dass wir über den Winter kommen die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber haben es am
Montag doch klar aufgeschrieben ist
droht weiterhin eine Notlage und deshalb
müssen alle Kapazitäten genutzt werden
das heißt da muss mehr gemacht werden
bei den Entlastung ist es unkonkret sie
haben jetzt wieder Ankündigung gemacht
obwohl sie doch den ganzen Sommer
darüber verhandelt haben wie
Normalverdiener die jetzt hat getroffen
sind besser unterstützt werden können
wie Betriebe unterstützt werden können
die Industrie Russland Russwurm war bei
ihrer Klausurtagung hat gesagt es geht
um die Substanz der Industrie sie haben
darauf keine Antwort bisher die
Bäckereien der Mittelstand alle weisen
darauf hin wie hart Sie getroffen sind
da gibt es Ankündigung aber nach
wochenlangen Beratung keine Antwort es
soll jetzt ein Expertengremium
eingesetzt werden das ist zu wenig es
ist zu langsam es muss konsequenter sein
und bei all dem wird der Klimaschutz
hinten angestellt und ich will es
konkret am Beispiel machen
Stresstest sie haben bei dem Stresstest
prüfen lassen auf Netzstabilität aber
sie haben nicht prüfen lassen auf die
Stabilität der Ökosysteme sie haben
nicht die Frage gestellt ob befristet
etwas länger Kernenergie weniger Kohle
damit weniger CO2 bedeuten könnte diese
Prüfung diese Frage liegt aber auf der
Hand sie ist aber kein Maßstab in ihrer
Prüfung deshalb setzen sie einseitig auf
die Kohle sie setzen einseitig auf das
Öl und deshalb fällt es auf Sie zurück
wenn Sie sagen
alles tun um aus dem fossilen Energien
rauszugehen das tun sie gerade nicht und
es wird deutlich bei der Bioenergie wir
haben hier im Deutschen Bundestag
beantragt den Deckel bei der Bioenergie
wegzumachen da könnt ihr jetzt
kurzfristig nicht erst langfristig
kurzfristig könnten Potenziale genutzt
werden des Mais liegt in den Lagern es
könnte jetzt mehr Strom mehr Wärme
Biomethan produziert werden im
Stresstest von Montag schreiben Sie auf
die Situation im nächsten Winter dieser
eine andere aus einigen Gründen und ganz
wichtiger Grund sei dann würde er mehr
Strom aus Biogas als Bioenergie zur
Verfügung stehen im nächsten Winter
werden sie unserem Antrag gefolgt wird
in diesem Winter zur Verfügung stehen
deshalb wenn sie sagen verbockt und
verhindert es fällt auf sie zurück das
haben sie verbockt deshalb sie
verhindert wir könnten in diesem Winter
mehr Bioenergie nutzen stattdessen sie
es erst ignoriert dann abgelehnt und
jetzt verbummelt sie haben im Juli dann
angekündigt sehen wir uns doch so machen
wie wir das beantragt haben im Juli es
gibt auch immer noch kein
Kabinettsbeschluss immer noch kein
kabinettsverschluss den wollen sie jetzt
im September machen das richtig dass es
jetzt machen aber es zu spät es ist
verbummelt es hätte mehr getan werden
müssen und es zeigt es wird eben
Klimaschutz und Energiesicherheit nicht
zusammengedacht und ich will es ganz
konkret machen am Klimaschutzgesetz auch
das was war eine Lehre es war die Lehre
aus dem Jahr 2019 dass die Klimaziele
nicht ausreichend verbindlich waren und
wir haben nach langer Diskussion
Umweltpolitiker vieler Fraktionen lange
wir haben lange dafür gekämpft und wir
haben es lieber Matthias Mirsch 2019
erreichen du hast im Deutschen Bundestag
gesagt wir werden es nie wieder eine
Minister durchgehen lassen dass der
Klimaziele nicht erreicht und das tun
sie jetzt sie haben sie haben die
gesetzliche Verpflichtung das ist kein
grüner Parteitagsbeschluss es ist nicht
das Wahlplakat eines selbst ernannten
klimakanz das ist eine gesetzliche
Verpflichtung aus dem Klimaschutzgesetz
zum 30 Juni diesen Jahres ein
Sofortprogramm vorzulegen zu Schließung
der klima-lücke sie haben nichts gemacht
ihre Experten haben die Vorschläge aus
dem Verkehrsministerium zerrissen die
haben den sogar die Ernsthaftigkeit
abgesprochen es gibt keinen Vorschlag
des widerspricht der gesetzlichen
Pflicht und es hat ja ein Sinn des zum
30 Juni gemacht werden sollte das
nachgesteuert werden können das
Sofortmaßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht
werden können und stattdessen wollen sie
das Klimaschutzgesetz das ihre Partei
als solax kritisiert hat aufweichen sie
wollen weg davon dass im jahresschreiben
und Sektoren des vorgelegt werden muss
das war aber gerade die Lehre gegen
verstoßen sie jetzt und deshalb muss man
sagen sie müssen mehr tun für
Energiesicherheit mehr tun für
Entlastung und mehr tun für Klimaschutz
sie müssen zusammenbringen das ist
unsere Erwartung herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Frank junge
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
lassen Sie mich vielleicht zunächst
einmal sagen Putins verbrecherische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ist
gleichzeitig auch ein von ihm bewusst
und von Anfang an kalkulierter
Nahrungsmittel und energiekrieg gegen
Europa und die Welt und Frau Wagenknecht
es ist erschütternd es ist erschüttern
Sie heute hier mit diesen Aussagen zu
hören sie könnten faktisch drüben Platz
nehmen das ist unisone genau das gleiche
was die AFD hier auch verlauten lässt
die die verheerenden Folgen dieser
Situation ist hier in voller Breite aus
vorgetragen worden und ich denke und das
ist auch noch mal ein Punkt den man ja
ganz klar herausstellen muss das was
diese Regierungskoalition auch mit
diesem Wirtschaftsminister und dem
gesamten Haus in den zurückliegenden
Monaten auf die Beine gestellt hat das
ist bemerkenswert davon muss man den Hut
ziehen wir wären mit anderen
Wirtschaftsministern untergegangen wir
haben die Wirtschaft an der Stelle am
Laufen gehalten die Energiesicherheit
sichergestellt und das ist eine
Situation die kann man nicht so
diskreditieren wie das hier gerade
vorgefallen ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor genau
diesem Hintergrund halte ich es für ja
für hanebüchen und für für Gaukelei wenn
Ihre Vorschläge Herr Merz aus ihrer aus
ihrer Fraktion darauf abheben dass sie
dass sie den Leuten scheinbar einfache
Lösungen sozusagen offerieren die aber
entweder gar nicht umsetzbar sind oder
aber am Ende noch viel viel teurer
werden als das was gegenwärtig zu
bewältigen ist der Punkt Atomenergie ist
ja hier schon angesprochen worden und
von dem Hintergrund ist das aus meiner
Sicht reiner Populismus den man hier
auch als solchen benennen muss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein Grund noch
während sie mit ihren scheinbaren
Vorschlägen oder gar kein konstruktiven
Beiträgen versuchen in der
Öffentlichkeit zu punkten mit markigen
Worten hat diese Regierungskoalition
drei entlastungspakete auf den Weg
gebracht die nicht nur dazu beitragen
die soziale Sicherheit und auch die
Solidarität ein Stück weit zu
unterstützen die auch gerade Unternehmen
im kleinen und mittelständischen Bereich
jetzt schon unterlassen entlasten vor
dem Hintergrund ist es aber für uns alle
eine Selbstverständlichkeit dass wir mit
diesem Maßnahmen nicht eben aufhören
sondern jetzt schon daran denken wie
geht es weiter die Fragen Strom mag die
sein angehen die Frage wie kriegen wir
eine vernünftige gaspreisbremse hin sind
ja hier schon erwähnt worden und genau
das müssen die zur Kenntnis nehmen bevor
sie hier in diesem Bausch und Bogen uns
kritisieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich komme noch mal ganz kurz
auf den Haushalt selbst des bmwk zu
sprechen natürlich und das unterstreiche
ich auch ausdrücklich der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien bringt uns neben
der Frage der krisenbewältigungen eine
Situation wo wir unsere Wirtschaft
insgesamt Krisen resilienter machen wo
wir dazu beitragen Sie unabhängig von
solchen Preisentwicklungen in
Energiesektor zu machen wie die die wir
gerade erleben und hier gestatte ich mir
auch noch mal den Hinweis dass wir jetzt
auch beim Ausbau der Stromnetze das
Ausmerzen müssen
Stichwort März was sie im Rahmen ihrer
bisherigen Politik mit verhindert haben
wenn wir also jetzt schon vernünftige
Stromnetze hätten könnten wir auch ganz
anders andere Bundesländer mit Ökostrom
versorgen das ist ein Versäumnis wo wir
jetzt gerade stehen müssen dafür aber es
auch anpacken werden und noch ein Punkt
will ich erwähnen es geht nämlich darum
dass wir mit diesem Haushalt nicht nur
die energietransformation die
Transformation der Wirtschaft die
Investitionen in Wasserstofftechnologie
in E-Mobilität in Energie Wärme und
mobilitätswende vornehmen es geht ja
auch darum in althergebrachter Form
klein und mittelständische Unternehmen
zu unterstützen und hier will ich ein
Beispiel nennen das wurde hier schon
ganz kurz erwähnt wir investieren damit
nämlich auch in die Fragen wie wir
Innovationsförderung aber auch Forschung
und Entwicklung weiter voranbringen
können und das ist eine Situation die
gerade diesen Unternehmen in
Größenordnungen zugute kommt und wenn
ich hier im Entwurf sehe das schon von
vornherein 80 Millionen Euro mehr drin
stecken und wir eine zentralen
Innovationsprogramm Mittelstand schon
auf 700 Millionen Euro
Investitionsmöglichkeiten kommen ist das
eine gute Entwicklung die man gerade für
diese Unternehmen hervorheben muss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen sie mich
zum Schluss sagen dass ich natürlich
auch an diesem Haushaltsentwurf
Verbesserungsbedarf sehe vor allen
Dingen dann wenn es um die Frage geht
die Gemeinschaftsaufgabe regionale
Wirtschaftsstruktur in Angriff zu nehmen
wenn wir die Frage diskutieren wie wir
schwächere wirtschaftliche Regionen
unterstützen können dann bietet genau
diese Kulisse hervorragende
Möglichkeiten und vor dem Hintergrund
ist der Haushaltsansatz für mich völlig
unzufriedenstellend das werden wir im
parlamentarischen Verfahren Regeln ich
lade sie alle zu konstruktiver Mitarbeit
ein vielen Dank
Frank Junge ist für die SPD im
Haushaltsausschuss und dasselbe gilt die
Mitgliedschaft im Haushaltsausschuss
jedenfalls für Wolfgang Wieler
fraktions- und parteizugehörig ist er
der AFD
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen bis vor kurzem
ist das Wirtschaftsministerium
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Energie der zweite Begriff Energie
musste dem Klimaschutz weichen das ist
bezeichnend dafür wie wenig eine sichere
Energieversorgung dieser Regierung noch
wert ist
anscheinend hat niemand analysiert wir
verletzlich unser Land die Bürger und
die Wirtschaft sind bevor man die
sanktionsspirale gegen Russland
losgetreten hat
und anscheinend hat auch niemand
analysiert was der gleichzeitige
Ausstieg aus Kohle und Kernkraft für die
Stromversorgung bedeutet wenn Wind und
Sonne nicht liefern dann hängt das Land
nun in fataler Weise von Gaskraftwerken
ab diese Politik ist ein völliger
Fehlschlag nur die Regierung will es
nicht zugeben
[Applaus]
jetzt reaktivieren Sie Herr Minister
Habeck sogar Kohlekraftwerke um den
großen Blackout vielleicht noch
abzuwenden ihre politischen Freunde von
Greenpeace
sagen heute schon öffentlich welchen
Preis das in der grünen Weltsicht hat
das zusätzliche CO2 aus der Kohle müsste
künftig wieder eingespart werden im
zusätzlichen Kohlestrom von heute
steckten nach dieser Logik also schon
die heizbeschränkungen die Fahrverbote
und die Betriebsschließungen von morgen
gerade mal eine Milliarde haben Sie
zusätzlich zur Stützung
energieintensiver Unternehmen damit Herr
Minister werden sie die
Deindustrialisierung Deutschlands nicht
verhindern an die Ursachen müssen wir
heran
[Applaus]
und im Mittelpunkt der Krise steht die
gescheiterte Energiewende
obwohl die Kernenergie dringend
gebraucht wird und noch dazu CO2 neutral
ist halten sie am Atomausstieg
halsstarrig fest und der Kollege
Partnerschaft hat das noch mal bestellt
zwei Kraftwerke für ein paar Monate in
Bereitschaft zu halten produziert keine
einzige Kilowattstunde und senkt den
Strompreis nicht um einen Zehntel Cent
so wird Deutschland mit dieser Regierung
zum Gefangenen der Ideologie grüner
Minister und der Grünen Partei die
Zukunft dieses Landes der Bestand
zahllose Unternehmen
hunderttausende Arbeitsplätze und die
Existenz genauso vieler Familien stehen
auf dem Spiel
[Applaus]
eine solche Partei meine Damen und
Herren ist absolut
regierungsunfähig mit diesen grünen darf
es keine Koalitionen mehr geben das sage
ich hier nicht nur den Kollegen von SPD
und FDP sondern auch von der Union denn
fast die Hälfte der Bundesbürger lebt in
Ländern mit schwarz-grünen Koalitionen
eines solche Partei die ihre Ideologie
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste über die
Interessen unseres Landes stellt gehört
abgewählt und zwar für Jahrzehnte
Wolfgang wiele aus der
afd-fraktion und hier geht es weiter mit
einem der profilierten oder
kenntnisreichsten
Umweltschutz und Klima
umwelt-fraktion Lukas Köhler inzwischen
auch stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender
meine sehr verehrte Präsidentin meine
lieben Damen und Herren keine Sorge
bleiben oben die Menschen haben sorgen
die Menschen haben sorgen in diesem Land
die Unternehmen haben Sorgen und für
viele ist diese Situation dramatisch und
wir stellen uns hier hin und
ehrlicherweise was wir in dieser Debatte
bisher geführt haben überrascht mich
doch sehr wir streiten uns darüber wer
Verantwortung für irgendwas übernimmt
und wir streiten uns darüber wer
Verantwortung übernehmen soll verstehen
Sie mich nicht falsch ich glaube es ist
absolut richtig und es ist wichtig dass
wir eine starke Opposition brauchen die
Stärke sollte aber nicht in rhetorisch
geschwungenen geschliffenen Worten über
Robert Habeck kommen sondern in der
Sache die Vorschläge müssen da sein und
wir müssen darüber diskutieren und
debattieren was wir verändern wollen um
dieses Land nach vorne zu bringen die
Leute wollen Streit in der Sache und wir
als
regierungstragende Fraktionen wir
liefern wir liefern eine Menge an Dingen
die dafür sorgen werden dass den
Menschen in Deutschland und den
Unternehmen in Deutschland besser gehen
und das ist richtig so es ist richtig so
dass wir darüber diskutieren wie wir es
hinbekommen und dass wir das geschafft
haben die Gasspeicher zu füllen meine
Damen und Herren es waren Kraftakt und
es ist ein Kraftakt dass wir bei 780%
sind und es sichert in Deutschland
weiter die Produktion und das Heizen ab
und es ist richtig dass wir in
mittlerweile drei entlastungspaketen den
Menschen da helfen wo es schwer für sie
ist den Menschen die wenig Geld haben
die Menschen die wenig Möglichkeiten
haben die hohen Kosten noch zu tragen
dass wir die entlasten ist völlig
richtig und das setzen wir als Regierung
konsequent um und ich finde darüber
können wir uns unterhalten da können sie
sagen das sind gute oder schlechte Ideen
wir können auch darüber streiten was für
eine Art von Wirtschaftspolitik wir
jetzt brauchen und ich glaube in einer
Inflation ist es absolut klar dass wir
eine angebotsorientierte
Wirtschaftspolitik brauchen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass Produktivität
gesteigert wird wir müssen auch darüber
nachdenken dass es ein nach der Krise
geben wird und das bedeutet dann die
Wirtschaft auch wieder wachsen muss dass
dann gute Jobs geschaffen werden müssen
das ist dann weitergehen muss und weiter
aufwärts gehen muss mit diesem Land und
das bedeutet dass wir jetzt in die
notwendige Bürokratie Abbau in den
notwendigen Bürokratieabbau investieren
müssen dass wir jetzt als Regierung
dafür sorgen müssen dass Dinge einfacher
werden und das machen wir das machen wir
täglich das machen wir wenn wir dafür
sorgen dass die Menschen bei den
Solaranlagen einfacher Ihre Geld
verdienen können dass sie nicht mehr so
viele Hürden haben das machen wir wenn
wir über die ganze Bürokratieabbau in
den Planungsprozessen sprechen das
machen wir mit einem
lng-beschleunigungsgesetz das in einer
Zeit vorgelegt wurde die ist die
unvergleichlich ist und die dafür sorgt
dass wir in enormster Geschwindigkeit
Dinge ans Netz bringen und das machen
wir auch wenn wir darüber denken
diskutieren und streiten wie wir in
Zukunft unsere Energieversorgung
ausrichten und dazu brauchen wir die
erneuerbaren Energien und zwar in
riesigen Maß aber wir brauchen auch über
den Winter und über den Winter zu kommen
jede einzelne Produktionskapazität
haben und deswegen sind wir im Moment
noch in der Diskussion darüber wie das
mit der Atomenergie weitergeht wir sind
der Meinung dass wir auch die drei im
Weiterbetrieb brauchen
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Claudia Müller
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Dietmar Bartsch ich muss
doch einmal ganz kurz meine Enttäuschung
ausdrücken
dass du die einzige Redezeit eurer
Fraktion hergegeben hast für eine Täter
opferumkehr für populistische und
falsche Argumente und nicht für Lösungen
sondern für den das Wort reden eines
Kriegsverbrechers ganz ehrlich das ist
auch eure Fraktion nicht würdig
wir sehen
an der Transformation der Wirtschaft
unsere Energieversorgung führt kein Weg
vorbei das gilt an Land wie auf See
Resilienz unserer Versorgungssysteme
geht nur mit einer starken
klimaneutralen Schifffahrt um mit
zukunftsfähigen Häfen wie zum Beispiel
in meiner Heimatstadt Rostock und
deswegen bin ich Robert Habeck und
seinem Haus sehr dankbar dass im
maritimbereich trotz der schwierigen
Haushaltslage vieles vorangebracht wird
aktuell findet in Hamburg die weltgrößte
Messe der Maritim Industriestadt die SMM
die Fragen die dort diskutiert werden
sind die grundsätzlichen
Wirtschaftsfragen die wir uns alle
stellen Energie Transformation
Sicherheit von Lieferketten Resilienz
und die maritime Welt spielt eine
entscheidende Rolle bei unserer
Versorgungssicherheit denn wir im und
exportieren in erster Linie per Schiff
jetzt Frau Müller Entschuldigung
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
afd-fraktion
und für die jetzt anstehenden Fragen der
kurzfristigen Energiesicherheit spielt
ebenfalls die Schifffahrt eine
entscheidende Rolle Stichwort LNG fsius
und auch lang und mittelfristig für den
Import von Wasserstoff und entsprechend
Derivaten ist die Schifffahrt und die
Häfen entscheiden und dabei werden wir
jetzt nicht vergessen wer jetzt für
andere Verantwortung übernimmt wie zum
Beispiel Rostock und Schwedisch
angesprochen wird worden für die
rohölversorgung für die Raffinerien
Schwedt das wird später bei
Investitionen beim Thema Wasserstoff
berücksichtigt werden und zweitens
natürlich auch beim Thema
offshoreenergie es spielt der
maritime-bereich eine entscheidende
Rolle denn es sind eben nicht nur die
Windkraftanlagen es sind Konverter
Stationen es ist die Kabelverlegung es
sind die check up check-up-schiffe und
natürlich auch hinterher der Service der
für die Sicherheit sorgt wir sehen
Energiepolitik und Wirtschaft und
Industriepolitik sind eng miteinander
verzahnt und im maritimenbereich für
fallen die Fragen der Energieproduktion
im und exportstrukturen und die Nutzung
zusammen deshalb ist die Unterstützung
für Projekte wie dem klimaneutralen
Schiff
Maritim Innovationsprogramm und der
innovationshilfen Werft sowie der
Forschung und Bereich der Entwicklung
maritime Energien Systeme so wichtig und
deshalb
ist die maritime
infrastruktursystemrelevant und wir
werden hier unsere Unterstützung
weiterhin Stärken stark halten und das
tun wir mit diesem Haushalt
Claudia Müller ist eine der
Koordinatorinnen für bestimmte
Aufgabenbereiche durch der
Bundesregierung in diesem Fall für
maritime Wirtschaft und in dieser Rolle
hat sie hier natürlich auch gesprochen
in der Debatte über den Etat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers jetzt die
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecherin der
Fraktion cdu/csu Julia Klöckner
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eines vorab ich
war mehr als irritierten jetzt beziehe
ich mich nicht auf irgendeine Sendung
sondern auf ihren Auftritt hier Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sie haben
einen merkwürdiges Demokratieverständnis
des die Opposition sie nicht beim
Regieren irgendwie stören soll ich kann
Ihnen sagen es ist gut dass wir sie mal
beim Denken gestört haben denn sie
hatten vergessen dass die Mehrwertsteuer
auf die gasumlage zum Beispiel noch
drauf kommt und wenn wir uns noch mal
anschauen
sie holen Zahlen raus werfen der Union
vor wir hätten jahrelang den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien speziell in Bayern
blockiert also wenn wir uns mal die
Tabellen richtig anschauen herr
Kretschmann grün aus Baden-Württemberg
hat jahrelang den Tabellenkeller
angeführt beim Windkraftausbau auch das
gehört
[Applaus]
am Ende ich verstehe dass sie unter
Druck sind und ich finde auch dass man
auch Verständnis haben muss dass eine
Regierung die im krisenmodus ist auch
Fehler macht aber was ich nicht
akzeptieren kann ist es hier geholzt
wird gegen eine Opposition die mit ganz
konkreten Vorschlägen hier in die
Diskussion geht und sich von ganz rechts
und ganz links abgrenzt weil wir wissen
was es heißt für dieses Land auch
Verantwortung zu übernehmen und dann
komme ich zur Wirtschaft und sie haben
heute in ihrer Rede die Wirtschaft die
Mittelständler die Industrie die Lage
wie sie ist noch nicht mal annähernd mit
einer Empathie versehen dass man sich
hoffen kann dass sie wirklich im ganz
konkretes arbeiten kommen ums konkret zu
machen
das Leibniz-Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung in Halle hat es
beziffert wir haben eine
insolvenzzahl oder Steigerung wir haben
26 Prozent mehr Insolvenzen im Vergleich
zu 2021 im Herbst wird es ansteigen ich
muss die Namen nicht alle nennen das
sind aber alles Arbeitsplätze das sind
Steuereinnahmen das ist
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland und am
Ende ist Ihre Antwort einfach nur das
dritte Entlastungspaket und dann gehen
wir doch mal rein in dieses sogenannte
Entlastungspaket da ist für die
Wirtschaft überhaupt nichts drin
die Wirtschaft ich habe manchmal den
Eindruck die Deindustrialisierung kommt
in grünen gerade recht damit sie ihre
co2-klimaziele erreichen aber
wirtschaftlicher Wachstum
Wohlstand sind doch kein Selbstläufer
denken Sie doch mal an die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
dieses Land zusammen mit ihren
Mitarbeitern am Laufen halten und dann
gehen wir doch mal rein in ihr Programm
da sagen sie sie wollen ein Programm für
energieintensive Unternehmen auflegen
die Steigerung Ihrer Energiekosten nicht
weitergeben können jetzt sagen sie gibt
es schon moment mal sie haben im
Entlastungspaket geschrieben sie wollen
eins auflegen wir schauen uns das Ganze
an hören aus dem Ministerium es muss
nachgebessert werden und wir alle wissen
bisher hat dieses Programm gar nichts
gebracht bei ihnen
Entschuldigung wollte in den Redefluss
nicht unterbrechen ich habe die Zeit
angehalten gestatten Sie eine Frage aus
der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen von
Herrn banatschak Frage oder
Zwischenbemerkung
jederzeit einer seine Sachen nicht
untergekriegt hat falsch verstanden
worden ist wie das öfter bei grünen ja
ist dann denke ich ist seine Zeit
gewesen zweiter Punkt das Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm soll für weitere
Unternehmen geöffnet werden die nicht
auf der kübelliste stehen ja wann kommen
denn diese Anpassung und für wen was
sagt die Europäische Kommission sind
alles
Unternehmen sollen bei Investitionen
Effizienz und substitutionsmaßnahmen
unterstützt werden ja und was heißt das
also sie alle sagen auch von der FDP wir
sind noch in der Diskussion solche Ihnen
was sagen während sie in der Diskussion
sind gehen bei den Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmern die Lichter aus und
Menschen verlieren ihre Arbeit wir haben
doch keine Zeit hier ständig noch in
Diskussion zu sein und deshalb bin ich
mehr als erstaunt über diesen Haushalt
den sie vorlegen sie kürzen die Mittel
für digitale Technologien die Mittel für
innovative Unternehmensgründungen sie
kürzen die Mittel für berufliche Bildung
und Mittelstand Fortbildungseinrichtung
ich kann nur sagen wir brauchen einen
Wirtschaftsminister und keinen
Insolvenzverwalter in dieser
Bundesregierung
Julia Klöckner aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
wo sie wirtschaftspolitische Sprecherin
ist und wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
ist auch Bernd Westphal allerdings kommt
er aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
wir sind in einer sehr schwierigen
Situation ohne Frage und alle
beschäftigt das sehr nicht nur hier uns
im Bundestag sondern auch die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer die
Menschen in unserem Land aber ich sage
Ihnen diese Reden die wir hier heute von
ganz links und ganz rechts in diesem
Haus gehört haben die angstschüre da
will ich nur sagen Angst muss in diesem
Land keiner haben diese Politik sorgt
dafür für gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt für soziale Entlastung wir
nehmen das ernst was hier diese
Situation vorträgt
diese ampelregierung noch nicht ein Jahr
im Amt hat mit wahrlich schweren Themen
zu tun und deshalb muss man das
honorieren was sie auf den Weg gebracht
worden ist das dritte Entlastungspaket
was neben kaufkraftsicherung und
sozialem Ausgleich auch Perspektiven
schaffen und deshalb hat der
Wirtschaftsminister zu Recht heute
morgen angekündigt dass wir die
Programme erweitern und öffnen werden
das Mittelstand und Industrie auch davon
profitieren und ich sage Herr Minister
wir müssen auch an die preissetzenden
Mechanismen dran so wie Gas und
Strompreise entstehen auf dem Markt
können wir nicht weiter zugucken das
können wir nicht kompensieren und
deshalb ist es gut wenn sie morgen im
Ministerrat in Brüssel darüber sprechen
mit unseren europäischen Freunden denn
wir sind in einem europäischen
Binnenmarkt und wir können es national
nicht alleine und vielleicht nehmen sie
als Idee noch mit einen europäischen
Industriepreis zu verankern das wäre
wirklich ein Fortschritt
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Reden von Frau Klöckner und gestern
von Herrn Merz muss ich sagen sie sind
wirklich Weltmeister im Problem
beschreiben diese Ampelkoalition ist
aber dabei dieses Land zu reagieren und
Probleme zu lösen und nicht nur zu
beschreiben und deshalb werden wir
deshalb werden wir in diesem
Bundeshaushalt und dessen um den geht es
ja hier in dieser Debatte naja also
gestern habe ich nur Zitate gehört und
irgendwelche Zeitungsartikel die hier
vorgelesen wurden keine vernünftigen
Konzepte wie man diesen
Wirtschaftsstandort in die Zukunft
entwickeln und das werden wir in der
Ampelkoalition machen
wir haben
wir haben hier eine Situation dass wir
mit Unternehmen
mit einer Transformation befindlich zu
tun haben die das Angebot erneuerbarer
Energien brauchen um eine Perspektive zu
haben das ist bei Stahlindustrie das ist
bei Chemie bei der Produktion von
Aluminium oder Kupfer der Fall und in
vielen anderen Bereichen ab gestern erst
im Harz mit einem metallerzeugenden
Betrieb gesprochen der heute mit Koks
Kohle und Strom die Stahlschmelze
organisiert der ist darauf angewiesen
erneuerbare Energien zu haben und weil
die Leitungsstruktur dort nicht
vorhanden ist bemüht er sich jetzt mit
Freiflächen Photovoltaikanlagen die
Energieversorgung zu organisieren mit
Wasserstoff auch die schwankende
Erzeugung das sind Unternehmen die
zuversichtlich anpacken und die Zukunft
organisieren um Arbeits- und
Ausbildungsplätze und Wertschöpfung zu
halten und das ist das was wir politisch
unterstützen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir haben mit dem Bundeshaushalt fast
ein Drittel die Investitionen erhöht das
zeigt doch schon dass diese
Bundesregierung dabei ist Mittel zu
organisieren die eben genau Unternehmen
bei dem Investitionen unterstützen
flankieren wir haben sehr erfolgreiche
Programme mit dem Zimmer was gerade
abhebt auf den Mittelstand wir haben mit
der GRW wie eben schon Frank junger
darauf hingewiesen ist ein Instrument wo
wir Regionen die wirtschaftlich zurück
sind helfen auch Anschluss zu halten und
wir haben weitere Potenziale die wir
nicht aus den Augen verlieren lassen und
deshalb sind in den
berichterstattergesprächen der
Haushälter vielleicht noch die Punkte
auch aufzunehmen mit dem ipsaal die sehr
erfolgreich in den Bereichen
Zukunftstechnologien wie Wasserstoff
etabliert sind auch die Frage der
Gesundheitswirtschaft mit aufzudecken
[Applaus]
und weiterentwickeln können und
sicherlich auch die Luft und Raumfahrt
ist ein Bereich der uns hilft die
Zukunft zu gestalten meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
die SPD ist sehr nah an denen
Unternehmen und der Entwicklung sie
können sich sicher sein dass wir mit
Betriebsräten mit Gewerkschaft mit
Unternehmen mit Management sprechen und
deshalb werden die nächsten Wochen
entscheidend sein und diese
entlastungspakete die auf den Weg
gebracht worden sind haben wir auch noch
Optionen Anschlussprogramme zu
finanzieren und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass diese Bundesregierung die über
ihren Koalitionsvertrag mehr
innovationsfragen beschrieben hat genau
diese Politik verankert und deshalb bin
ich zuversichtlich auch den Menschen
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und
Zukunft mit positiven Politik zu
begleiten vielen Dank
Bernd Westphal aus der SPD-Fraktion
deshalb wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
ist folgt Carsten Hülse aus der
afd-fraktion ob man im Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz und Energie
[Applaus]
mache ich Frau Präsident meine Damen und
Herren liebe Landsleute der
Haushaltsentwurf zeigt sehr deutlich
dass sich die dümmste Energiepolitik der
Welt nicht nur auf fatale Weise den
Geldbörsen der Menschen und in den
Bilanzen der unternehmerwiege
widerspiegelt sondern auch im Haushalt
der durch die Grünen Kommunisten
angeführten Bundesregierung statt in
dieser fundamentalen und seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg schlimmsten
Wirtschaftskrise alle Mittel einzusetzen
um diese zu bewältigen wird das Geld der
Steuerzahler zum Fenster hinausgeworfen
Milliarden werden für grünkommunistische
Luftschloss ausgegeben die Mitstreiter
im Geiste NGOs und klebstoffsüchtige
Arbeitsschuhe Elemente alimentiert und
die Vernichtung der wertschöpfenden
Industrie in Deutschland vorangetrieben
viele Mittelständler gehen jetzt rein
weil sie aufgrund der explodierenden
Energiepreise Pleite sie bekommen nach
den sinnlosen
lockdown-maßnahmen nun den Rest dank der
schon von vergangenen Regierungen
praktizierten und nun
energieverknappungspolitik als
gegenrezept empfiehlt
wirtschaftszerstörer Robert Habeck allen
Ernstes die Unternehmen sollten doch
einfach aufhören zu produzieren aufhören
zu verkaufen dann müssten sie nicht in
die Insolvenz gehen dümmer geht immer
ihre Aufgabe ist es zuallererst Schaden
vom deutschen Volk abzufinden und seinen
Wohlstand zu mehreren sie tun das genaue
Gegenteil sie verknappen böswilliger
Absicht bezahlbarer Energie wodurch die
schon vorher höchsten Energiepreise der
Welt nun durch die Decke gehen das
Abdrehen der Gasversorgung durch
Russland als Antwort auf Sanktionen
vertrags- und Wortbruch wirkt dabei nur
als Brandbeschleuniger denn sie sie
allein zusammen mit ihren willfährigen
Vorgänger Regierungen haben diesen Brand
gelegt und die Lunte schon vor vielen
Jahren gezündet Klimaschutz und
Energiewende nennen sie es in Wahrheit
wahr und ist es ein Programm zur
Zerstörung unserer Wirtschaft und
Verelendung des deutschen Volkes die AFD
hat diesen Irrweg von Anfang an rein
ideologisch begründet benannt es gibt
daher nur eine Richtung Kohleverstromung
Förderung deutschen schiefergases laut
Bundesbehörde 2,5 Billionen Kubikmeter
und natürlich nur zum Verkehr lassen Sie
die sichersten Kernkraftwerke der Welt
weiterlaufen fahren Sie stillgelegten
Kraftwerke wieder hoch die die
technischen und Sicherheitsbedingungen
erfüllen CDU und FDP fordern allen Orten
auch hier im Parlament den Weiterbetrieb
der Kernkraftwerke unsere Fraktion ist
allerdings die einzige die einen
entsprechendes Gesetz eingebracht hat
sie können gemeinsam mit uns dieses
Gesetz beschließen tun sie es nicht
würden sie und das muss ich leider sagen
auch wenn ich einige ihrer Kollegen
Schätze sind sie nur erbärmliche Häuser
die zwar große Töne spucken aber im
entscheidenden Moment den Schwanz
einziehen die Menschen die für Frieden
Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung auf der
Straße sind beweisen dass man trotz
unterschiedlicher politischer Grund
überzeugend gemeinsam etwas erreichen
kann das Kippen der allgemeinen
Impfpflicht hat jedem Menschen gezeigt
es macht Sinn für seine Rechte zu
demonstrieren und ich hoffe dass ich in
diesem Herbst viele Menschen ihre Macht
bewusst werden und sie die Deutschland
Zerstörer hier auf der Regierungsbank in
die Schranken weisen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ich muss ein kurz durchatmen aber uns
wir haben uns vereinbart uns nicht mit
irgendwelchen Titeln zu belegen und
erbärmliche Heuchler sollten wir uns
hier im Hause nicht gegenseitig nennen
bitte Sie in Zukunft auf ihre Wortwahl
zu achten
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Reinhard Huben und
reinhardspolitischer Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das Niveau der Debatte ist zum Teil
schon schwerlich zu ertragen aber Frau
Klöckner dass sie hier antreten und sich
über
Holzen in der Debatte beschweren
dann aber keine Zwischenfrage zulassen
und
dieser Regierung zu unterstellen wir
würden systematisch für die
Deindustrialisierung dieses Landes
sorgen zu wollen das ist afd-niveau Frau
Glöckner
und lieber Herr Spahn lieber Herr Spahn
16 Jahre ist ja für die FDP nicht das
Thema
aber die Bundesregierung für die
Bekämpfung der Krise in den letzten
sechs Monaten zu kritisieren
ist im Vergleich zur Professionalität
der Probleme zu corona-zeiten auch ein
bisschen schräg denn die Maßnahmen die
während der corona-maßnahmen getroffen
wurden haben den Mittelstand
bisher zumindest mehr geschadet als alle
Unternehmungen dieser Bundesregierung
der Energiekrise zu bekämpfen und es ist
uns vorgeworfen worden ja ihr habt ja
noch gar nichts gemacht also ja die
höheren zu die hören zu deswegen kommen
sie nicht zum Klatschen sie haben uns
vorgeworfen sie hat ja noch gar nichts
gemacht das ist doch Irrsinn das ist
doch nur wirklich Irrsinn wir bauen
lng-terminals als Zwischenlösung kommen
die eva-jugends
wir kaufen wo möglich Gas ein wir
schieben an die Kohle
Stromversorgung das machen wir doch
alles Kohle wird eingekauft es ist doch
nicht so dass man ein Atomkraftwerk oder
ein Kohlekraftwerk einfach an und
ausschaltet sie müssen ja
beschaffungswege Sie müssen doch
beschaffungswege ermöglichen das ist
doch möglich es tut mir leid also Fragen
aus der AFD nehme ich nicht wollte ich
gerade Fragen
gut und deswegen die beschaffungswege
sind eröffnet aber wissen Sie die Kohle
kommt doch nicht mit dem Flugzeug die
muss ja erstmal über eine Logistik auch
herangebracht werden und deswegen finde
ich diese Vorwürfe die sie hier machen
wirklich an der Realität vorbei
und
seien Sie gewiss wir haben am Donnerstag
die Maßnahmen debattiert als Ampel heute
am Sonntag die Fragen der Entlastung
debattiert heute ist Donnerstag morgen
wird es unter Umständen auf europäischer
Ebene eine Lösung geben also noch nicht
mal eine Woche und das als langsam zu
bezeichnen finde ich auch ein bisschen
schwierig eine letzte Bemerkung
Preisbildung
Preisbildung am Energiemarkt ich will es
mal unidiologisch einführen wenn die
OPEC beschließt
im nächsten Monat die Ölförderung zu
steigern dann singt am nächsten Tag der
öl-weltmarktpreis
und so ist es eben auch beim Strom und
deswegen ist die FDP der festen
Überzeugung dass wir in dieser Notlage
die drei AKWs die uns zur Verfügung
stehen noch einmal mit Brennstäben
ausstatten und sie über anderthalb bis
drei Jahre entsprechend der Not dann
auch betreibt vielen Dank
[Applaus]
bevor ich die nächste Rednerin Aufrufe
hat jetzt das jetzt das Wort zu einer
Kurzintervention aus der afd-fraktion
Rainer Kraft ja vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin Herr Huben ich komme nicht
umhin ganz kurz noch sie haben die Frau
Klöckner kritisiert dass sie keine
Zwischenfrage zugelassen hat sie haben
es dann selber gemacht nur eine
brandbemerkung wenn sie Kernkraft gut
finden wunderbar in zwei Wochen gibt es
ein gesetzesentwurfantrag meiner
Fraktion dazu der ist sehr simpel
gehalten den kann man zustimmen dann
läuft passiert genau das was Sie möchten
aber die eigentliche Frage ist sie haben
sehr viel vom LNG gesprochen den
fsa-news und deswegen die konkrete Frage
als sie als regierungstragende Koalition
wie viel unterschriebene Kontrakte für
wie viel Milliarden normkubikmeter LNG
Gas liegen in der Zeit vor wie viel ist
bereits gekauft denn erst dann kann das
Gas bei den Verbrauchern ankommen
sie dürfen Antworten
immer Fragen zu bin jetzt fünf Jahre in
diesem Hause
aber in den fünf Jahren hat sich ihre
Fraktion einfach derartig aus der
Debatte
herausgebrüllt und gepöbelt dass ich das
nicht machen möchte und das bitte ich
als persönliche Entscheidung zu
akzeptieren
sie fragen nach dem konkreten Zahlen
weiß ich nicht nein ich werde auch nicht
schätzen wir sind doch hier nicht bei
einer quizveranstaltung das
Wirtschaftsministerium arbeitet an den
Zahlen machen Sie eine kleine Anfrage an
den Wirtschaftsminister wird Ihre Frage
schon beantworten danke
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Lisa badum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren wenn die
Beiträge aus der Union heute so gehört
hat das muss ich einfach nur sagen bin
wirklich froh dass sie nicht mehr in der
Regierung sind denn das Ausmaß des
Ausmaß der Realitätsverweigerung mit dem
Sie hier antreten mit wenn sie nicht
fähig Entscheidungen zu treffen und das
ist genau das was wir tun Entscheidungen
treffen auf der Basis von Fakten und was
die Atomenergie betrifft sind die klar
so gut wie kein Beitrag zur gasansparung
so gut wie kein Beitrag zur Senkung des
Strompreises und ein geringer Beitrag in
einem extremen Notfall zur Sicherung der
Netzstabilität das ist die Wahrheit und
da können Herr Söder und Herr Merz noch
so oft vor dieser zwei posieren davon
wird sich nichts ändern
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommen wir zum klimaschutzjahr
jung den die Union jetzt in dieser
Legislatur für sich entdeckt hat ich
begrüße das und sie haben natürlich
Recht der Verkehrsbereich muss mehr
liefern und deswegen haben wir 1,5
Milliarden mehr für die Schiene
eingestellt aber
klar ist klar ist es muss mehr kommen
und dann schlage ich einfach vor dass
die unionsregierten Länder heute schon
mal die Straßenbauprojekt die nicht
benötigt werden an den Verkehrsminister
schicken das ist sicher eine gute
Hilfestellung
es ist so
jetzt kommen wir aber zum Balken zum
klimaschutzbalken ihrem eigenen Auge ein
kongeniales Duo von Herr Altmaier und
ich weiß nicht wer damals bayerischer
Ministerpräsident war haben ja die
bayerische windkraftverweigerung
gestützt und Herr Dobrindt ist wundert
mich nicht dass ich heute nicht ans
redepult trauen weil als fremden als
Bayern muss ich sagen diese
Wehleidigkeit dieses jammern wie sie nur
mit dem Finger nach Berlin zeigen das
geht mir so auf den Geist übernehmen sie
endlich Verantwortung für das Land
Bayern ist
bürgerenergieland bioenergie-land Bayern
kann windenergiland werden und wenn wir
es hier schaffen zehn Gesetze zu Energie
und Klima im Bundestag zu verabschieden
dann werden sie es wohl hinbekommen ein
energiewendegesetz zu verabschieden und
das ist die Abschaffung der
zehnhar-regel in Bayern und zwar zackig
das erwarten wir
Lisa bardum aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen wo Sie ob Frau im Ausschuss
für Klimaschutz und Energie ist
bemängelt
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen in Bayern nächster
Redner ist hier Hans-jörg durtz aus der
Unionsfraktion ob man im
Wirtschaftsausschuss
Kollegen ihnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren für
Politik gibt es viele Definitionen doch
eine gilt ganz besonders in Krisenzeiten
und die lautet politik ist die Kunst des
Möglichen
wenn man diese Definition anwendet habe
ich große Zweifel ob die Ampel in dieser
Krise wirklich Politik gestaltet
denn sie weigert sich in einer der
größten Krisen dieses Landes alles zu
tun was möglich ist
und
und die völlig und die völlig vom
volksregasumlage die auch noch die
Inflation anheizt
hat gezeigt wie weit es mit der
regierungskunst her ist
ob nun als zufallsgewinn Abschöpfung
oder ein neues Strom Marktdesign die von
ihnen angekündigten
Ideen war auch nicht nur Zeit sondern
lösen nicht die Ursachen des
Preisanstiegs auf den Energiemärkten
sondern dämpfen allenfalls die Folgen
denn die größte Energiekrise seit
Jahrzehnten ist vor allem eines ein
angebotsschock und wie reagiert man
zuallererst auf einen angebotsjob man
muss dann alles Angebot ausweiten und
alle möglichen Kapazitäten ohne
ideologische Scheuklappen ans Netz
bringen
und es gilt eben auch für Biomasse und
es gilt eben auch für die befristete für
den befristeten Weiterbetrieb von
Atomkraft und wenn Sie uns das schon
nicht glauben dann können Sie zumindest
auf die FDP hören die das ja auch
einfordert
und die Wirtschaftsweisen
die übrigens folgendes auch gesagt haben
die Atomkraftwerke ans als Notreserve
einzusetzen mal abgesehen davon ob das
technisch überhaupt möglich ist steht ja
auch noch in der Diskussion aber sie als
Notrecht Seife einzusetzen hat die
Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm als die
schlechteste alle Möglichkeiten
bezeichnet weil man nämlich weiterhin
die Kosten hat aber kein Strom
produziert wird der eine positive
Wirkung auf den Strompreis hätte und
unsere Betriebe und Handwerker brauchen
dringend und zwar schnellstmöglich
niedrigere Strompreise
denn
er gut anhören sie halt auf die
Wissenschaft und die FDP die sehr wohl
alle der Meinung sind das ist sehr wohl
Wirkung auf den sturmpreis hat
denn der Bäcker wird sein Brot nicht
erst dann nicht mehr backen können wenn
er gar keine Energie mehr hat sondern
dann wenn er zum Beispiel aufgrund der
Knappheit die extrem hohen Preise nicht
mehr bezahlen kann oder wenn er der
Preise nicht mehr weitergeben kann an
seinen Kunden und der einzige Ausweg ist
dann die Produktion zu stoppen und
Mitarbeiter nach Hause zu schicken ein
Vertreter meiner Handwerkskammer hat mir
an diesen Tagen gesagt im Handwerk
stirbt man still
ihre Aufgabe als Wirtschaftsminister ist
es deshalb das Angebot an Energie
auszuweiten allein schon um den immensen
Preissteigerungen entgegenzuwirken denn
einer der einfachsten
volkswirtschaftlichen Lehrsätze lautet
Angebot hoch dann sinkt der Preis und da
hilft jede zusätzliche Kilowattstunde
darüber hinaus sind
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen mit Sicherheit
auch notwendig Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm ist im Grundsatz
richtig nur wirkt es nicht und wirkt es
vor allem nicht für die kleine
mittelständischen Unternehmen sie haben
angekündigt dass sie dort jetzt mit
einem Rettungsschirm agieren wollen
allerdings hätten sie über Monate Zeit
gehabt den auch vorzubereiten das heißt
es wird jetzt endlich Zeit dass diese
auch umgesetzt wird sie müssen handeln
auch beim Strom insbesondere auch
Verkleidung mittelständische Unternehmen
und um einem angebotsschock zu begegnen
braucht es in einer sozialen
Marktwirtschaft dringend auch Innovation
und Leistung der haushaltsentwerfer
zeigt in innovativen Bereichen auch
Kürzungen darüber müssen wir in den
Haushaltsberatungen reden das kann nicht
sein im Grunde im Gegensatz dazu
übrigens ist der Haushaltsposten
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit des bmwk deutlich
angestiegen bedienen sie sich nicht
allein der Kunst des Redens sondern vor
allem der Kunst des Möglichen vielen
Dank
Hansjörg durz aus der CSU Landesgruppe
Obmann im Wirtschaftsausschuss des
Deutschen Bundestages der den Einzelplan
09 des Haushalts
2023 diskutiert bzw den ersten Entwurf
für das Haushaltsgesetz 2023 und in
dieser Debatte ist jetzt die dritt
letzte Rednerin dran Nina Scheer aus der
SPD-Fraktion Sprecherin für Klimaschutz
und Energie
wegen und Kollegen
die bettbeginn mit ein paar Fakten aus
dem Haushalt die ganz klar eines
erkennen lassen auch wenn natürlich über
das letzte Wochenende noch mal weitere
Haushaltstitel angeklungen sind die dann
noch im weiteren zu aufzugreifen sein
werden wir haben einen kräftigen
aufwuchs gegenüber dem letzten Jahr und
wir haben in zentralen Bereichen auch
den internationalen klimaschutzbereichen
einen Zuwachs wir haben
Investitionsanreize mit Zusatz das Zim
ist mit Zuwachs versehen allerdings
haben wir auch tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen klärungsbedarfe wie das eben
ist auch für ein ordentliches
parlamentarisches Verfahren gehört dass
dazu auch bei der neuen Mobilität bei
den grb-mmitteln und auch noch bei
Auslandsinvestitionen um nur einige
Sachen zu nennen ich möchte aber auch
erwähnen dass wir mit dem KTF also im
Klima transformationsfonds über einen
Jahreszeitraum einen den Zeitraum von
2023 bis 26 und das fällt dann leicht
hinten runter wenn einfach nur im
jahreshäppchen rechnet dass wir da
177,5 Milliarden Euro investieren wollen
und das ist natürlich schon eine
Hausnummer die unmittelbar anknüpft an
das was sich im Übrigen in der
Gesetzesmaterie tut und da haben wir
schon eine ganze Menge im ersten
Halbjahr auf den Weg gebracht selbst
wenn wir viele notfallgesetze machen
mussten mit dem Ostpaket sind auch mit
einer großen EEG-Novelle viele Hemmnisse
abgebaut werden für erneuerbare Energien
viele Hemmnisse abgebaut worden und
weitere hemmnisabbauten werden auch noch
kommen mit den nächsten Paketen
und zur Wahrheit gehört eben auch dass
wir hier enorm viel aufzuräumen haben
wir haben es ja auch schon in der großen
Koalition erlebt wie mühselig es war
Fortschritte für erneuerbare Energien
reinzuverhandeln auszuverhandeln die
Gegenwehr zurückzudrängen die leider in
den reinen cdu/csu über Jahre vorhanden
waren das war ein mühseliges Geschäft
und häufig sind darüber Kompromisse
entstanden die wenigstens ein bisschen
mehr Wert für die Erneuerbaren
bedeuteten aber häufig auch Komplexität
geschaffen haben und das jetzt alles so
zurückzudrehen dass wir tatsächlich
diesen Booster für die Erneuerbaren
hinkriegen den wir brauchen das ist
wirklich auch kein einfaches Unterfangen
und in diesem Sinne haben wir schon eine
ganze Menge geleistet
[Applaus]
man muss dazu sagen wenn wir jetzt im
Moment darauf schauen wie kriegt man die
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet dann
haben wir natürlich einmal die
finanzielle Fähigkeit einer Gesellschaft
die es zu stärken gilt da haben wir
jetzt mit der Vereinbarung über das
dritte Entlastungspaket schon einen
weiteren dicken meilenstein-gesetz den
es in die Umsetzung zu überführen gilt
wir haben aber natürlich auch die
weitere Fähigkeit
aus der Gesellschaft heraus mit den
Unternehmen aus den Unternehmen heraus
mit entsprechenden Rahmenbedingungen
auch sich weiter aus der führe
herausführen zu können deswegen muss
doch miteinander verzahnt werden einmal
zielgenau und möglichst wirklich
zielgenau auch dort wo der Schuh am
meisten drückt sowohl bei den
Unternehmen als auch bei den privaten
Haushalten anzusetzen mithilfen aber
zeitgleich eben auch die Weichen immer
weiter ein Stückchen weiter zu öffnen in
Richtung Transformation in Richtung
erneuerbare Energien und hier möchte ich
auch betonen klar wir haben eine Menge
erneuerbaren Energien Ausbaubedarf das
ist ohnehin auf unserem Zettel auf
unserem unserer Habenseite bei vielen
Gesetzesänderungen die wir schon gemacht
haben aber wir können auch wenn wir
jetzt akut uns überlegen wie können wir
noch mehr Energie reinbringen in den
Markt dann haben wir auch noch eine
ganze Menge schon installierten
erneuerbare Energien es liegt noch
weiter ausgelastet werden können wir
haben zum Beispiel Nacht Absenkung für
Windkraftanlagen sie sind Lärm bedingt
durchaus in gewissen Rahmen sinnvoll
aber jetzt in der Krisenzeit kann man
sehr wohl überlegen lasst uns daran wir
brauchen wir können diese Potenziale
brauchen sie sind installiert das
gleiche bei Bioenergie natürlich und das
hat da braucht uns auch nicht cdu/csu
erst drauf zu bringen das ist natürlich
schon längst auf dem Zettel das ist
schon längst in Arbeit da brauchen wir
keine Nachhilfe das ist schon längst in
Arbeit
und sie wissen auch ganz genau deswegen
der verweiser jung ich glaube Sie haben
es erwähnt dass da jetzt noch mit dem
Antrag irgendetwas wird wir eine
Entscheidungshilfe bräuchten von ihrer
Seite mit irgendwelchen Anträgen die in
der haushaltswoche ohnehin nicht ziehen
nein diese Dinge sind das wissen sie
auch ganz genau sie wollten
wahrscheinlich jetzt so so so so wirken
als ob sie schneller sein aber wie
gesagt es ist haushaltssache danach in
den nachfolgenden Wochen werden solche
Anträge wieder behandeln und dann haben
wir natürlich eine Überarbeitung des
energie-sicherungsgesetzes und das zeigt
auch die Handlungsfähigkeit der
Koalition und im Rahmen dessen wird
natürlich auch weiter an den
Befähigungen in Richtung erneuerbare
Energienutzung gearbeitet vielen Dank
Nina Scheer aus der SPD-Fraktion hat
gleich mehrere Abkürzungen verwendet in
ihrem Redebeitrag ein will ich Ihnen
auflösen Tim das ist das zentrale
Investitionsprogramm Mittelstand eins
der Förderprogramme des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums und
ungefähr in acht neun Minuten geht's
hier weiter mit dem Einzelplan
Gesundheit und der zuständige Minister
ist wie Sie sehen auch schon da Karl
Lauterbach wir schauen zurück ans Pult
da steht Andreas Mattfeld aus der
Unionsfraktion Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss
ist ja wirklich ein bisschen demütiger
in diesen Tagen ihre ihre
Selbsteinschätzung zu Beginn ihrer Rede
Herr Habeck ich darf Ihnen das sagen die
hat mich fassungslos gemacht fassungslos
gemacht wie sie sich selber sehen und
wie die realen Ergebnisse sind die sie
hier vorzuweisen haben und dabei habe
ich Ihnen im Frühjahr gesagt dass ich
sie nicht um ihren Job beneide ich habe
ihnen sogar Respekt gezollt weil ich den
Eindruck hatte dieser Mann stellt
Parteipolitik hinten ran und ich habe
sie hierfür sogar öffentlich gelobt was
in meiner Fraktion nicht so gut ankam
das darf ich ganz deutlich sagen ich bin
selten so enttäuscht worden wie von
ihnen her Habeck das darf ich in aller
Öffentlichkeit sagen und ich sage Ihnen
wenn nur der Publicity wegen agiert
wer hinterher nicht liefert der wird das
Vertrauen der Menschen schneller
verlieren als er sich selbst vorstellen
kann und deshalb auf eine
anständige Performance und die geben sie
wirklich öffentlich ab der muss vor
allen Dingen eine gute aber auch
schnelle Umsetzung erfolgen nur mit
quatschen nur mit medialen Auftritten da
haben sie ja habe ich noch kein Problem
gelöst und dass der Maischberger
Auftritt totaler Quatsch und total lost
war ich glaube das hassen sie haben sie
selbst gemerkt in so einer
existenziellen Krise wie sich unser Land
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr
erlebt hat da dürfen einfach
handwerkliche Fehler und Versäumnisse in
dieser Art nicht passieren das sind bei
ihnen
keine Einzelfälle mehr ja frau
Präsidentin entschuldigung dass ich es
gibt eine Frage oder Zwischenbemerkung
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
aber sehr gerne
sie dürfen
über Kollege Mattfeld vielen Dank wo sie
das jetzt gerade ansprechen würde ich
gerne sie fragen ob sie zur Kenntnis
nehmen wollen zu Beginn der
Ampelkoalition als wir das hier
übernommen haben
dass dort geplant war Nord Stream 2 in
Betrieb zu nehmen das dort die
Gasspeicher so leer waren wie eigentlich
im Jahresdurchschnitt nie im Oktober
letzten Jahres viel zu wenig Gas war
eingespeichert und dass sie in den
letzten 16 Jahren die erneuerbaren
Energien blockiert haben statt
vorangebracht und deswegen stehen wir da
wo wir jetzt stehen
und wollen sie zur Kenntnis nehmen das
Nord Stream 2 jetzt gestoppt ist dass
derzeit sogar nicht mal mehr durch Nord
Stream 1 Gas fließt dass die Gasspeicher
so gut gefüllt sind wie im
Jahresdurchschnitt seit langem nicht
mehr und dass diese ampelregierung noch
vor dem Sommer ein massives
Gesetzespaket zur Beschleunigung der
erneuerbaren Energien umgesetzt hat das
sind so viele Gesetze wie selten ein
anderes Ministerium in so kurzer Zeit
umgesetzt hat wollen Sie diese
Leistungsbilanz zu Kenntnis nehmen
heimatfeld ich freue mich sehr Frau Dr
Christmann dass sie mir diese Frage
stellen insbesondere zu Nord Stream und
jetzt sage ich mal Nord Stream 2 da gibt
es auch Nord Stream 1 und wollen sie zur
Kenntnis nehmen das nordstream 1 ihre
Erfindung ist sie Nord Stream 1 mit an
den ich sag's mal an die Versorgung
gebracht haben das war zu ihrer
Regierungszeit insofern auf andere
Finger zeigen hilft hier in diesem Fall
überhaupt überhaupt nicht sie haben dann
und diese Frage mir zu stellen diese
Frage mir zu Gast speichern zu stellen
das ist schon eine Frechheit diese Frage
müssen sie ihren Koalitionspartner
Stellen
2014 hat erwirtschaftsminister Sigmar
Gabriel die Gasspeicher in Reden die
erdgaskonzessionen in Niedersachsen an
Gazprom verkauft ich war seinerzeit
Mitglied der Regierungskoalition und das
macht man sehr selten dass man als
Mitglied können Sie doch zu der balatsch
hat dass man als Mitglied einer
regierungstragenden Koalition den
eigenen Wirtschaftsminister kritisiert
warum er das in dieser Phase gemacht hat
wir erinnern uns 2014 ist gerade die
Krim überfallen worden und der SPD dem
Wirtschaftsminister Gabriel fällt nichts
anderes ein als den gastspeicher Reden
an gastron zu verkaufen ich habe dafür
einen Skandal gehalten
und sie haben noch eine dritte Frage
gestellt die mindestens die Präsidentin
hat das ja zugelassen diese mehr davon
wir hätten bei Windenergie nichts getan
Frau Dr Christmann
2005 waren wir wenn ich es richtig weiß
bei 5 Prozent sind Energiestrom heute in
den Jahren danach sind wir bei 50 im
Moment über 50 Prozent das hat diese
Regierungskoalition mit Partnern die
auch hier in der Mitte sitzen die Geld
waren auch gemacht und wenn ich das
sagen darf ich war viele Jahre
Altbürgermeister fast zehn Jahre wir
haben uns größte Mühe wir haben uns
größte Mühe gegeben Wind Energie
auszuweisen es waren ihre Leute allzu
häufig vor Ort die das verhindert haben
und deshalb hier
Minister Habeck was für erleben sind
keine Einzelfälle die gasumlage die ist
mit Verlaub solch ein Murks gewesen sie
wäre gar nicht notwendig gewesen weil
sie mit dem Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds ein Instrument
haben wie sie dieses Problem zu einem
Großteil hätten lösen können eine
weitere Luftnummer das war doch die
Energiepartnerschaft mit Qatar die nicht
vorankommt nicht ein Kubikmeter Gast
wurde hier ratifiziert und konnte zu
einer Entspannung der Märkte beitragen
der Gaspreis Herr Habeck der ist auch
dadurch durch die Decke gegangen weil
sie auch in Norwegen in Kanada nichts
erreicht haben und vom abrupten Stopp
ihrer CO2-Gebäudesanierung da redet
schon keiner mehr und deshalb es ist
schon verwunderlich sie präsentieren uns
in diesen Tagen jetzt einen
Haushaltsentwurf in dem sie sogar die
Wirtschafts- und Klimapolitik
gegeneinander ausspielen das ist
übrigens auch gegenüber den 10.000 38
Mitarbeiter müssen uns auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen über 10.000 Mitarbeitern
in Geschäftsbereich nicht fair sie haben
jetzt für 2023 für das harbeckhaus 13
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung im Entwurf
das sind 1,7 Milliarden Euro mehr als
2022 die ausgabereste türmen sich auf
mittlerweile über zwei Milliarden Euro
auf und natürlich geht bei Ihnen auch
die
stellenausweisungsorgie noch wieder
munter weiter noch einmal bringen sie 49
Stellen an top auf wobei sie den
nachgeordneten Behörden zugunsten ihres
Mutterhauses sogar noch Stellen
wegnehmen Herr Habeck es ist schon
seltsam ich komme jetzt noch mal zum
paar Punkten im Haushalt da gibt es eine
Verliererseite das ist bei Ihnen im
Hause ganz klar die Mittelstandspolitik
der sie 56 Millionen Euro also gut 5%
streichen bei der Außenwirtschaft die
für den Export zur existenziell wichtig
ist streichen Sie 286 Millionen Euro
also fast ein Drittel bei der deutschen
Zentrale für Tourismus die wollen sie
anscheinend kaputt schießen kürzen Sie
wieder 5 Millionen das sind fast 30%
weniger als noch bei Herrn Altmaier und
im Bereich luft- und Raumfahrt aber eben
59 Millionen Euro und bei der
lehrlingsunterweisung und bei
Fortbildungseinrichtung für
Auszubildende wird der Rotstift auch
noch mal richtig angesetzt
der Arbeit sie haben natürlich auch eine
Gewinnerseite das ist beispielhaft die
Investition die Investition zum Schutz
der Biodiversität im Ausland im Ausland
dir hält über 685 Millionen Euro mehr
obwohl bislang in diesem Jahr lediglich
magere 110 Millionen abgeflossen sind
sie haben auch kryptisches das ist die
energiepolitische Zusammenarbeit mit der
Ukraine die wird erneut mit 50 Millionen
Euro angesetzt obwohl bislang kein Euro
abgeflossen ist gleiches gilt für den
wirtschaftsfonds Afrika eigentlich eine
tolle Sache aber 10 Millionen Euro und
keine Abflüsse im laufenden Jahr da
frage ich mich was da los oder was ist
da besser nicht los bei Ihnen und
deshalb Herr Habeck ich würde mir wenn
ich Wirtschaftsminister wäre schon die
Fragen stellen ist das jetzt der
richtige Moment bei den Lehrlingen in
unserem Land zu kürzen Stichwort
schlimmster Fachkräftemangel ever ist
das jetzt der richtige Moment bei der
gebeutelten Tourismuswirtschaft noch
einmal zu kürzen Stichwort Umsatzausfall
durch Corona und ist das jetzt der
richtige Moment bei der wertschöpfenden
Industrie und bei Hochtechnologien zu
kürzen Stichwort Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in
einer globalen Wirtschaft für Harbeck
sie können nicht für die globale
Gesamtlage etwas sie wirken aber das
darf ich Ihnen sagen krisenverstärkend
und nach 14 Haushalten in ihrem
Ministerium darf ich sagen das ist das
Schlimmste der schlimmste Entwurf den
ich in 14 Haushaltsjahren für das bmwk
erlebt habe eigentlich müsste dieser
Haushalt noch einmal mit Blick auf die
derzeitige Krise ganz neu aufgestellt
werden herzlichen Dank
Andreas Mattfeld aus der Unionsfraktion
und weil er seine Zeit als Bürgermeister
erwähnt hat Andreas Mattfeld kommt aus
dem Wahlkreis 34 Osterholz Verden das
ist natürlich Niedersachsen und in
Niedersachsen ist am 9 Oktober
Landtagswahl Lena Werner ist die letzte
Rednerin in dieser Debatte noch mal aus
der SPD-Fraktion
wirtschaftsrelevanten Aspekt eingehen
und zwar den Tourismus hat der Kollege
ja auch gerade schon aufgegriffen
natürlich sind Urlaubsreisen und
Restaurantbesuche eine Art Luxusgut und
in Krisenzeiten ist das wahrscheinlich
das erste worauf man dann verzichtet
aber wir brauchen alle mal eine Auszeit
und das kann ganz unterschiedlich sein
es kann eine Wandertour durch die Eifel
sein das kann ein Städtetrip sein ein
Strandurlaub oder eben auf dem
Campingplatz nebenan und gerade in
diesen Zeiten der Krise ist das für
unsere mentale Gesundheit besonders
wichtig und unsere Gesellschaft befindet
sich schon zu lange im krisenmodus die
gesamte Tourismusbranche wurde in den
letzten beiden Jahren hart getroffen
erst die corona-pandemie mit
weitreichenden Folgen und nun folgt
direkt eine Energiekrise und eine
Inflation dazu kommt er seit Jahren
wachsende kräftemangel umso wichtiger
ist es jetzt dass wir weiterhin Geld in
unsere touristische Infrastruktur
investieren um sich zukunftsfähig zu
machen
dazu zählt die Unterstützung vielen Dank
Herr Kollege der deutschen Zentrale für
Tourismus die zentrales maßgeblich für
das Marketing für den Tourismusstandort
Deutschland zuständig und für einen gut
funktionierenden Tourismus braucht es
neben Marketing der aber auch die
entsprechende Infrastruktur und
Rahmenbedingungen und als
Querschnittsbranche wird der Tourismus
von den Vorhaben der Koalition
maßgeblich profitieren
durch den Ausbau des ÖPNV und dem
vorhergesehenen vorgesehenen
bundesweiten Anschlussticket für das
9-euro-ticket schaffen wir einen
bezahlbaren und unkomplizierten
Nahverkehr und dessen Nutzung ist eben
für Einheimische aber auch Gäste sehr
attraktiv durch die Modernisierung der
Einwanderungsgesetze und der Stärkung
der dualen Ausbildung bekämpfen wir den
Fachkräftemangel und schaffen
Erleichterung in der Tourismuswirtschaft
und das Gastgewerbe in der Krise
weiterhin zu entlasten haben wir uns
darauf geeinigt die Reduzierung der
Umsatzsteuer auf Speisen zu verlängern
das schafft Planungssicherheit für die
Gastronomie und hier möchte ich mich vor
allem noch mal bei unserem Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz dafür bedanken
auch von der Kulturförderung des Bundes
profitierter Tourismus maßgeblich die
Aufrechterhaltung und Pflege unserer
Kulturdenkmäler sowie die vielfältige
deutsche Kulturlandschaft sind für viele
Besucher in entscheidende Faktoren
Deutschland zu bereisen und deshalb ist
es umso bedeutsamer dass das
Bundesprogramm Neustart Kultur
verlängert wurde davon profitiert die
Veranstaltungswirtschaft und der ganze
Kulturbereich und einen letzten Punkt
möchte ich noch erwähnen es ist auch
weiterhin ausschlaggebend dass wir in
anderen Ländern besonders im globalen
Süden finanziell unterstützen der
Tourismus ist nicht nur bei uns eine
starke Wirtschaftskraft für viele Länder
trägt dazu nachhaltigen Entwicklung und
finanziellen Unabhängigkeit bei das ist
für feministische Entwicklungspolitik
und deshalb ist es elementar dass
Deutschland weiterhin an internationalen
Projekten zur nachhaltigen
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung sich
beteiligt und damit stärken wir den
Tourismus eben auch weltweit vielen Dank
Lena Werner war die letzte Rednerin in
der ersten Beratung des Einzelplans 09
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz der Etat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers Robert Habeck
und jetzt wird weiter diskutiert in den
zuständigen Ausschüssen und da vor allem
dann auch im Haushaltsausschuss und auch
wenn sich Andreas Mattfeld gerne einen
völlig neuen Einzelplan gewünscht hat
einiges wird hier durchaus noch
verändert werden in den
Haushaltsberatungen der kommenden Wochen
im November dann zweite und dritte
Lesung hier im Plenum auch wir kommen
zum Einzelplan 15 das ist der für das
Gesundheitsministerium und der fällt in
diesem Jahr deutlich kleiner aus als der
Vorgänger Etat im vergangenen Jahr der
ja noch überwiegend von Jens Spahn
verwaltet worden ist als
Gesundheitsminister zumindest bis Anfang
Dezember seitdem ist Karl Lauterbach in
Amt und Würden er muss mit 22 Milliarden
Auskommen im Jahr davor waren es 64
Milliarden die dem Haushalt zur
Verfügung standen aber da ging es auch
um Impfstoffe
Testzentren maskenbeschaffung auch ein
wichtiger Punkt Corona ist nicht weg und
deswegen wird es auch ein Thema in
seiner Rede jetzt sein am Pult während
die Abgeordneten hier noch ein klein
wenig rotieren
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind der
Haushaltsdebatte für das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium ich möchte
beginnen indem ich mich zunächst einmal
bei allen Haushälterinnen und
hausheltern für die guten Beratungen
ganz herzlich bedanke wir haben einen
großen Haushalt hier zu verabschieden
der Hausarzt schrumpft allerdings von
derzeit 64 Milliarden auf 22 Milliarden
im nächsten Jahr also auf ungefähr ein
Drittel das ist damit zu erklären dass
wir davon ausgehen dass die Pandemie im
nächsten Jahr uns nicht mehr vor teurer
und unlösbare Probleme stellen wird ich
rechne damit dass wir in diesem Herbst
noch einmal Schwierigkeiten bekommen für
diese sind wir aber sehr gut vorbereitet
diese Vorbereitung werde ich später
vortragen in der Diskussion um das
Infektionsschutzgesetz ich konzentriere
mich jetzt auf die Situation wie wir das
Gesundheitssystem modernis werden aber
ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass ich
davon ausgehe dass wir im Herbst die
Pandemie Lage gut im Griff haben werden
und das werde ich später ausführen
jetzt geht es um die Zukunft unseres
Gesundheitssystems und das sind im
Hintergrund
zahlreiche Projekte der Modernisierung
weitergeführt worden ich werde mich in
meiner Rede auf mehrere Bereiche
konzentrieren ich fand zunächst einmal
an indem ich darauf eingehen werde was
wir verändern werden in der Pflege dann
werde ich auf krankenhausreformen zu
sprechen kommen dann den Bereich der
Digitalisierung und dann schließlich das
was wir für sozial benachteiligte
Menschen tun wollen um das
Gesundheitssystem gerechta zu machen ich
fange einmal an mit der Pflege in der
Pflegeheime tatsächlich wichtige
Reformen vor uns und eine ganz konkrete
Reform sogenannte Krankenpflege
entlastungsgesetz beschäftigt sich mit
dem Problem was machen wir eigentlich
gegen die chronische Überlastung der
Pflege in vielen Stationen auch in
vielen Bereichen was wir dort machen ist
zunächst einmal wir gleichen ab durch
ein Instrument wo man den Pflegebedarf
vergleichen kann mit der Pflege die
angeboten wird welche Stationen sind
eigentlich besonders überlastet und wenn
wir diese Überlastung dann feststellen
dann kommt eine entsprechende Entlastung
entweder durch mehr Urlaubstage durch
entlastungstarife oder durch Zuschläge
die steuerfrei und abgabenfrei
organisiert werden können das führt dazu
dass tatsächlich die Pflege als
Arbeitsplatz wieder interessant ist man
kann ja zunächst mal die Frage stellen
was bringt es denn überhaupt wenn ich
nur auf der Station die Überlastung der
pflegedokumentieren naja werden wir in
diesem Gesetz vorgesehen dann
tatsächlich eine Entlastung auch kommt
dann wird die Pflege als Arbeitsplatz
wieder interessanter und wir wissen dass
ungefähr 300.000 Pflegerinnen und
Pfleger bereit sind im Prinzip wieder in
die Pflege zurückzukehren dieses Gesetz
wird dazu einen wesentlichen Beitrag
lassen das ist Grund weshalb das Gesetz
auch von den Gewerkschaften nicht nur
unterstützt sondern auch gefordert wird
dafür bedanke ich mich wir werden mit
diesem Gesetz ja die Pflege wieder
deutlich attraktiver machen und dem
Pflege Notstand entgegenwirken
im Krankenhaus muss mehr geschehen und
ich fange mit einem Bereich an der mir
besonders am Herzen liegt und zwar den
Kinderkrankenhäusern wir haben ungefähr
350 Kinderkliniken
Abteilung und Kliniken für Kinder und
diese Kliniken haben in den letzten
Jahren deutlich gelitten auch dort gibt
es einen Reformstau wir haben dort etwas
vorbereitet und zwar eine weitgehende
Reform und zwar dass die Kinderkliniken
komplett aus dem Bereich der
fahrpauschalen entfernt werden damit
wird der Druck der ökonomische Druck auf
diese Kliniken der wird von jetzt auf
sofort wird er beendet die Kliniken
können dann wieder die Kosten abrechnen
bekommen ein Budget und müssen nicht
durch Leistungssteigerungen quasi das
Budget sich von Jahr zu Jahr erkämpfen
neu erkämpfen das heißt hier haben wir
dann an Bereich der komplett ohne die
pauschalen im Wesentlichen nach dem
System der Kostendeckung funktioniert
gerade bei den Kindern ist das unbedingt
notwendiges es kann nicht länger
akzeptiert werden was wir viel zu lange
akzeptiert haben dass in der
Kinderkrankenhaus Versorgung ökonomische
Aspekte im Prinzip Einfluss auf die
Therapieentscheidung haben das können
wir nicht hinnehmen und da ist das ein
Gesetz was wir mit den Ländern
vorbereiten wir werden auch mehr Geld in
die Hand nehmen die Kinderheilkunde
würden in den Kliniken deutlich
entlassen wir gehen aber weiter auf dem
Krankenhaus wir werden auch die
fahrpauschalen allgemein entlasten und
zwar dann geht die Fahrzeugschein haben
derzeit keine Vorhaltekosten die
pauschal sind die abdecken wie stark ist
ein Krankenhaus eigentlich gebraucht die
Fallpauschale gibt im Prinzip den
gleichen Preis in einer Region wo es
sehr viele Krankenhäuser gibt und wo es
schon Überversorgung gibt und Regionen
wo es eine Unterversorgung gibt und wir
wollen jetzt durch eine
vorhaltepauschale dort mehr Geld
hinsteuern wo die Krankenhäuser
unbedingt benötigt werden und dafür soll
es Abschläge geben relative ab
freigegeben dort wo eine Überversorgung
ist damit steuern wir im Prinzip die
Krankenhausversorgung sehr viel besser
wir geben Anreize dass tatsächlich die
demografische und die medizinische
Situation dafür verantwortlich ist wo
investiert wird auch das ist eine
wichtige eine sehr sehr wichtige
entökonomisierung unserer
Krankenhausversorgung überfällig sie
kommt jetzt sie wird vorbereitet wir
sind mit den Sachverständigen schon in
einer konkreten Umsetzungsplan
nicht vergessen werden darf dass wir
auch die kurzfristigen Bedürfnisse der
Krankenhäuser hier berücksichtigen wir
werden die Energiekosten
inflationskosten die zurückgegangenen
Fallzahlen werden wir also analysieren
wir werden an Hilfspaket Schnüren damit
die Krankenhaus ja jetzt nicht in der
Situation wo 40 Prozent der
Krankenhäuser Liquiditätsprobleme haben
in unüberbrückbare Schwierigkeiten
kommen auch da arbeiten wir an einer
kurzfristigen Lösung wir lassen in
dieser Energie und
inflationskrise lassen wir unsere
Krankenhäuser nicht im Stich und werden
Sie über den Herbst über den Winter
bringen das haben wir vor dafür werden
wir konkrete Vorschläge in den nächsten
Wochen vor vorlegen und mit den Ländern
beschließen
ich komme zum Bereich der
Digitalisierung in der Digitalisierung
des Gesundheitswesens ist der Bereich
über den am meisten gesprochen wird und
wo am wenigsten passiert wir sind nach
wie vor was Digitalisierung angeht im
Prinzip im europäischen Vergleich eine
Entwicklungsland wir können nicht
mithalten mit Ländern wie Dänemark den
Niederlanden geschweige denn mit Ländern
außerhalb von Europa zum Beispiel Israel
wo einfach viel mehr möglich ist viel
mehr möglich ist was wir jetzt machen
wir bauen auf die Pandemie hat ja nur
Nachteile gebracht die schreckliche
Pandemie hat nur Nachteile gebracht aber
in einem Bereich hat sie tatsächlich
etwas angestoßen in der Digitalisierung
bei der Digitalisierung ist es zu viel
mehr
fehlersprechstunden gekommen
telekonsultationen das elektronische
Rezept ist möglich geworden wir haben
Pflegeberatung digitalisiert wir haben
mit der corona-warn-app die Versicherten
quasi herangeführt an die
Digitalisierung wir wollen darauf Aufbau
wir sind da jetzt sozusagen in einer
Kurve eingewogen wir wollen aus der
Kurve heraus beschleunigen und wir
wollen einführen das elektronische
Rezept letzte Woche eingeführt wir
wollen einführen die elektronische
Arbeitsunfähigkeitsbescheinigung 23
Millionen Mal schon genutzt bis zum
August wir wollen der elektronische
Patientenakte als ob Auslösung einführen
damit ist sozusagen jeder zunächst
einmal mit einer elektronischen
Patientenakte unterwegs und wir wollen
diese dann aber auch für
Forschungszwecke nutzen indem wir das
System was in Israel praktiziert wird
des digitalen zwillingsnutzen um aus
Routinedaten heraus Forschung machen zu
können sodass wir aus den Routinen Daten
heraus sehen können welche
Behandlungskonzepte sind effizienter
funktionieren besser das ist ein
wesentlicher Schritt nach vorne dafür
reisen wir wir sind mit den Israelis
diesbe im engen Kontakt aber dafür
reisen wir am Samstag mit einer
Delegation von Experten nach Israel und
werden einen Kooperationsvertrag
unterschreiben wir orientieren uns hier
an den besten und Israel ist was die
Digitalisierung des
gesundheitsamtsystems angeht weltweit
führend das wollen wir aufgreifen wir
wollen mit den besten zusammenarbeiten
und greifen das auch aus der Kurve
heraus beschleunigen Digitalisierung
wird ein wesentlicher Schwerpunkt der
Arbeit unseres Hauses werden
und lassen sie nicht
und lassen sie nicht zum Schluss noch
einmal sagen wir müssen noch etwas tun
für die Ärmste wir dürfen sie nicht
zurücklassen wir wollen mit 1000
gesundheitskiosken das sind ein das sind
neue Strukturen wo man an einem Termin
bekommt für ein Facharztbesuch
beispielsweise kein Hausbesuch wo
Vorbeuge Leistungen abgerufen werden
können wo es soziale Dienste abgerufen
werden können wo hebammendienste also
vermittelt werden können wo man
Übersetzungen bekommen kann wo
Pflegeberatung stattfinden kann wo
Ernährungsberatung mit 1000 Kiosken in
den
ärmsten oder in einigen der ärmsten
Stadtteile und Regionen Deutschlands
bauen wir eine neue Struktur auf die ist
längst hätte geben müssen dass es in den
ärmeren Stadtteilen eine
niederschwellige schnelle gute
Zugangsmöglichkeit gibt für die Menschen
auch die Menschen die in Sprache nicht
gut sprechen auch die Menschen die zum
Beispiel gar keine Versicherung noch
keine Versicherung haben die die keinen
richtigen guten Zugang haben wir müssen
das machen das spart auch Geld das spart
Notfall Einweisung das spart
Krankenhauseinweisungen das führt zu
einer besseren Medizin wir helfen hier
den Ärmsten dass es uns sehr wichtig das
haben wir also eine Priorität ausgeholt
wir haben viel vor wir machen viel auch
schon im Hintergrund wir machen nicht
nur Pandemie sondern wir machen viel für
die Modernisierung das ist ja es ist
klar dass sie davon weder etwas
verstehen noch mitbekommen aber es ist
so es ist so und ich danke denjenigen
ich danke denjenigen die diesen Weg
begleitet haben ich danke Ihnen auch für
den großzügigen Haushalt den werden wir
benötigen und den werden wir effizient
einsetzen danke schön
der Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach zu seinem Etat für das Jahr
2023 Corona die Pandemie hatte anfangs
erwähnt da wird er nachher in der
Debatte über das Infektionsschutzgesetz
ausführlicher zu berichten hat er eben
angekündigt ansonsten die Schwerpunkte
Pflege mit dem Krankenpflege
entlastungsgesetz die krankenhausreform
wo er insbesondere die Kinderkliniken im
Blick hat und das Thema oder ein großes
Thema die Digitalisierung im
Gesundheitswesen wie das elektronische
Rezept oder die elektronische
Patientenakte ich gehe davon aus dass
Sie damit einverstanden sind und damit
entfallen diese Tagesordnungspunkte und
das Wort geht an Sepp Müller für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Bundestag
Vizepräsidentin hat noch ein paar Punkte
gestrichen von der heutigen Liste des
Bundestages aber da geht es natürlich
nicht um die einzeletats der bleibt
alles so wie es ist nächster Redner Sepp
Müller aus der Unionsfraktion einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
ihre Worte höre ich gerne nur allein mir
fehlt der Glaube Faust Johann Wolfgang
Goethe kommen sie endlich aus dem Modus
des ankündigungsministers in den
machminister werden sie
Gesundheitsminister verlassen Sie die
corona-pandemie und kümmern Sie sich um
unser Gesundheitssystem
sie hatten nach der letzten Welle im
Frühjahr angekündigt dass endlich Zeit
ist um Gesetzesvorlagen vorzulegen aus
ihrem Haus kamen zwei die
gesundheitskioske tausend an der Zahl
angekündigt wissen Sie was ein
gesundheitskiosk im ländlichen Raum und
für die meisten Städte bedeutet das ist
die Hausarztpraxis wir brauchen
Hausarztpraxen
4.000 Hausarztpraxen in unserem Land
sind seit über zwei Jahren nicht besetzt
und sie diskutieren tausend zusätzliche
gesundheitskioske wo das Material nicht
da ist wo das Geld nicht vorhanden ist
wo das Personal fehlt was sie vorgelegt
haben ist ein
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz für die
gesetzliche Krankenkasse das ist weder
ausreichend noch der Lage und vor allem
den Problemen in unserem Land
gerecht schauen wir unserem Haushalt an
dann kann der geneigte Leser zu dem
Entschluss kommen dass der
Bundesfinanzminister mit dem roten Stift
dem roten Karl Lauterbach etwas diktiert
hat
ihre Ideen für diesen Haushalt
umfassen keine seltenen Erkrankung
wie sieht es aus mit den tausenden
MS-Erkrankten was ist mit der
Volkskrankheit Alzheimer wie geht es
weiter mit der Bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche Aufklärung all das Herr
Lauterbach haben sie in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten und wir
finden in ihrem Haushalt nichts kommen
sie weg vom ankündigungsminister werden
sie endlich Gesundheitsminister
und der Lauterbach nur ein Wort zu
Corona sie haben Ende letzten Jahres
Anfang diesen Jahres sich mit Millionen
Impfdosen eingedeckt diese werden jetzt
verfallen das sind dreistellige
Millionenbeträge die an Steuergeld
verbrannt war hätten sie dieses Geld
medizinischen Fachangestellten
zahnmedizinischen Fachangestellten als
Bonus gezahlt dann wäre das der Respekt
gewesen den wir auch von einem
Gesundheitsminister für diese Branche
erwarten
Herr Gesundheitsminister die
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung steht auf Töne und
Füßen bereits jetzt werden knapp 17
Milliarden Euro angenommen die fehlen
mit der Inflation werden wir bei 25
Milliarden Euro rauskommen sie sprachen
davon als sie das Gesetz eingebracht
haben nicht an der Qualität zu streichen
und zu arbeiten was legen sie vor sie
wollen die neue patientenregelung für
Ärzte streichen wissen Sie was das für
Hausärzte und Fachärzte bedeutet sie
werden an der Qualität streichen weil
sie neue Patienten junge Patienten
Patienten die von A nach B Umziehen nach
keinen Termin mehr geben können weil das
Budget voll ist sie sind der Minister
der die Axt an die Wurzel des
Qualitätssystems in unserem
Gesundheitswesen anlegen sie haben da
versagt Herr lauterbach
und wenn sie alleine das umsetzen würden
was in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag steht wie
die Beteiligung des
Bundesfinanzministeriums und
jahresministeriums BMAS bei der Frage
der Finanzierung der GKV spricht die
ALG2 Empfänger komplett mit zu
beteiligen hätten wir 10 Milliarden
zusätzlich zur Verfügung und die
brauchen wir und Liebe Sozialdemokratie
da haben sie uns an ihrer Seite da
werden wir sie auch unterstützen das
muss jetzt endlich auf dem Weg gebracht
werden und der Lauterbach werden sie
endlich Gesundheitsminister und kommen
sie weg von den anderen Themen danke
Sepp Müller war das aus der
Unionsfraktion zum Etat des
Bundesgesundheitsministers und ich kann
ihnen auch fix nachtragen welche Punkte
hier heute nicht aufgerufen werden das
ist nämlich die Wahl eines
Vizepräsidenten aus den Rhein der AFD
und die Wahl eines Mitglieds für das
Parlamentarische Kontrollgremium auch da
fehlt noch ein Vertreter oder eine
Vertreterin der AFD beide Wahlen finden
nicht statt weil die AFD von sich aus
diesen Tagesordnungspunkt quasi
zurückgezogen hat ampult ist Paula piota
dafür Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Mitglied im Haushaltsausschuss und
Ärztin übrigens
morgen besser wird aber wenn sich jetzt
hier hinstellen und sagen wir brauchen
dann mach Minister und das nur knapp 12
Monate nachdem ihr ins Spahn abgetreten
ist wo wir alle wissen dieser dieser
Ansatz von Politik viel zu machen
auch mit den Konsequenzen dass da
einfach unglaublich viel Geld aus dem
Fenster rausgeworfen wurde sie haben ich
will nicht in alle inhaltlichen Punkte
ein einsteigen weil ich nicht im
Fachausschuss mit mit hauptberuflichen
sitze aber wenn Sie jetzt hier zum
Beispiel die neupatientenregelung
ansprechen sie tun so als ob die
Streichung unglaubliche Unterschiede in
der Versorgung machen würde sie erwähnen
nicht wie wenig neue Patienten diese
Regelung tatsächlich geschaffen hat wie
viele zusätzliche Arzttermine sie
tatsächlich geschaffen hat oder aber
eben nicht was wir ja jetzt machen
müssen nach so viel Zeit Union und vor
allen Dingen auch Jens Spahn im
Bundesgesundheitsministerium der regiert
hat in Zeiten wo er klotzen konnte und
eben oft nicht aufs Geld geschaut hat
ist dass wir das jetzt ausbaden und das
unglaublich schwierigen
Rahmenbedingungen tun weil einfach das
Geld uns jetzt an allen Ecken und Enden
fehlt und hierzu zu tun als ob Karl
Lauterbach nicht mit Geld umgehen könnte
wenn man selber die Partei der Masken
Deals ist der Betrugsfälle in den
corona-test ist vielleicht ein bisschen
unvorsichtig in so einer
und jetzt möchte ich dann doch wieder
über das Geld sprechen aber noch mal
daran erinnern wie das war am Anfang der
Pandemie am Anfang der Pandemie wo wir
alle aus unserem Alltag rausgeworfen
waren und wo tatsächlich gefühlt
Gesundheitspolitik in Deutschland zum
ersten Mal viele Menschen interessiert
hat das war ja wirklich gerade für
Menschen die viel Gesundheitspolitik
gemacht haben eine sehr besondere
Situation und da haben viele auch hier
im Bundestag die Hoffnung gehabt dass
sich nach der Pandemie unglaublich
vielen Gesundheitswesen verbessern würde
gerade auch beschäftigt im
Gesundheitswesen die sehen jetzt sophie
hat sich gar nicht verändert und die
haben die blöde Vermutung dass wir aus
dieser Pandemie rauskommen könnten mit
genau den gleichen Problemen aber noch
weniger Geld im Gesundheitswesen und
damit auch noch schlechteren
Arbeitsbedingungen für Sie in die
Kliniken und Praxen
und deswegen muss man schon mal darauf
hinweisen dass es dann doch Lerneffekte
aus der Pandemie gibt auch in diesem
gesundheitsetat der Etat des
Gesundheitsministeriums der finanziert
nicht das komplette Gesundheitswesen der
ist nur ein Bruchteil dessen was die
Kassen in diesem Wesen leisten aber auch
an diesem Etat sieht man wie die
Lerneffekte der corona-pandemie jetzt
auch ganz konkret umgesetzt werden wir
haben zum Beispiel und der Minister hat
sehr angesprochen wir hatten dieses
diesen unglaublichen aufwuchs von vor
der Pandemie knapp 15 Milliarden Etat in
weniger als drei Jahren quasi
vervierfacht auf über 60 und jetzt
nehmen wir das wieder zurück auf knapp
22 Milliarden im Entwurf das zeigt aber
auch wir gehen nicht auf vor
krisenniveau zurück sondern wir bleiben
deutlich mit den 22 Milliarden über dem
vorpandemischen Niveau und da sind
Punkte drin die Lerneffekte darstellen
aus der Pandemie zum Beispiel ich möchte
auf drei Punkte eingehen weil ich auch
glaube dass wir die alle über alle
Fraktionen hinweg gut im Blick behalten
sollten weil die teilweise auch sehr
teuer sind aber nicht nur weil sie teuer
sind wir jetzt mit diesem Entwurf ein in
die sogenannten Pandemie
bereitschaftsverträge das ist ein neues
Instrument da geben wir Herstellern als
Bund hohe dreistellige Millionenbeträge
über mehrere Jahre an die Hand damit sie
Kapazitäten vorhalten für
Impfstoffproduktion falls es nochmals
von der epidemischen oder pandemischen
Lage kommt und das müssen wir alle sehr
genau im Blick behalten vor allen Dingen
auch ob die Kapazitäten die da
geschaffen werden sollen tatsächlich
auch zuverlässig geschaffen werden die
beratungshotlines für die Patienten
werden weitergeführt das ist auch eine
Errungenschaft der Pandemie und was auch
eine Errungenschaft ist ist ja die
Erkenntnis dass gerade in der Frühphase
der Pandemie die WHO nicht immer
suffizient die frühe Detektion die frühe
Vorwarnung die frühere Beratung von
Regionen und Ländern geleistet hat und
deswegen finanzieren wir jetzt weiter
den who-hub vor pendaming intelligence
und während das hier in Berlin als
Zentrum etablieren wo eben
früh-detektion und Warnung und Beratung
für alle Regionen und Länder dieser Welt
geleistet wird das sind Verbesserungen
in diesem Etat aber natürlich ist es so
dass in diesem Etat gerade auch aus
Sicht von gesundheitspolitikerinnen und
Gesundheitspolitikern natürlich
unglaublich viel Luft nach oben ist und
ich kann für uns sprechen vor allen
Dingen die punkteprävention
Modernisierung Gesundheitswesen und
internationale Gesundheitspolitik werden
wir uns noch mal sehr genau anschauen
aber jetzt möchte ich noch mal auf die
haushaltspolitischen Lehren aus der
corona-pandemie für diesen Etat kommen
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt ich
hätte möchte sie eine Zwischenfrage
zulassen aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
ausnahmsweise nicht aber ich komme
gleich vorbei ich habe gerade schon
gesagt von knapp 15 Milliarden Euro und
drei Jahren hat sich dieser Etat
wirklich das ist kann man nicht als
organisches Wachstum bezeichnen für
vierfacht auf über 60 Milliarden und die
Möglichkeiten und die Realisierung der
Kontrollmöglichkeiten ist da oft nicht
in gleichem Maße mitgewachsen und
deswegen ist auch haushaltspolitisch aus
dieser Zeit lernen auch in der Krise
auch im Gesundheitsbereich auch wenn wir
jetzt in die nächste Krise gehen und ihr
begegnen müssen brauchen wir den fairen
Lastenausgleich zwischen Bund und
Ländern teilweise auch den Kommunen es
gilt auch Gesundheitsbereich und es muss
auch im dritten und im vierten Pandemie
ja gelten und eben nicht nur im ersten
wie wir das erlebt haben auch in der
Krise müssen wir sicherstellen dass
Steuergelder so ausgegeben werden dass
Betrug verunmöglicht wird das ist eine
enorm große Lehre aus der corona-zeit
gerade im Einzelplan 15 wir sehen jetzt
dass teilweise Gelder zurückfließen aus
Betrugsfällen aber das ist nur ein
Bruchteil dessen was wahrscheinlich
wirklich nicht bei PatientInnen und der
Bevölkerung angekommen ist und wir
müssen natürlich auch schließlich
erstellen gerade wenn jetzt eine Krise
nach der anderen kommt und das eine
Hilfspaket das nächste ablöst dass das
was wir an Kriseninterventionen machen
nicht unsere Mittel- und langfristigen
Ziele im Gesundheitswesen zum Beispiel
im Bereich Krankenhauslandschaft
konterkariert
deswegen sehen Sie es uns bitte nach wie
Haushälter werden auch in diesem
Haushaltsberatungen uns wieder sehr
genau jeden einzelnen Euro anschauen bei
jeder einzelne Euro der hier eben nicht
dafür ausgegeben wird das
Gesundheitsversorgung besser und
Arbeitsbedingungen im Gesundheitswesen
attraktiver werden das ist ein Euro der
eine verpasste Chance ist für bessere
Lebenserwartungen und deswegen und
deswegen sehen Sie es uns nach wir
werden das wieder sehr genau beraten
vielen Dank
der Bundesgesundheitsminister hat zu
Beginn dieser Debatte gesagt dass er
sich später mit der Pandemie
beschäftigen wolle die Abgeordneten
beschäftigt das Thema schon jetzt Paula
picchiotta zum Beispiel eben ist unter
anderem eingegangen auf Betrugsfälle im
Gesundheitswesen rund um covid 19 jetzt
eine
Kurzintervention aus den Reihen der
Union auch der Grünen wobiotta immer
Behauptung in den Augen stellen und wenn
dann eine Zwischenfrage gestellt werden
soll diese Zwischenfrage nicht zulassen
meine kurze Intervention mich würde
interessieren ob sie mit mir auch einer
Meinung sind wenn sie hier schon
ankündigen und sagen wir brauchen gerade
als Ergebnis als Erkenntnis aus der
Pandemie wieder in besseren
Gesundheitsstandort in Deutschland
sprich Produktion Forschung Entwicklung
wir brauchen Hilfe für den
Gesundheitsstandort Stichwort
Energiepreis Explosionen in den Kliniken
brennt die Hütte lichterloh das wissen
Sie wir werden erste Insolvenzen
bekommen wir werden wenn die Regierung
weiter so untätig bleibt wirklich
Versorgungsprobleme bekommen weil
Kliniken schließen müssen dass sie sich
hier hinstellen und in einer süffisanten
Art zu tun wir werden machen wir könnten
der Bundesgesundheitsminister hier
wieder nur Ankündigung gebracht hat ich
sage immer wir können froh sein dass es
im deutschen den Konjunktiv gibt er
möchte er wird er könnte ob sie mit mir
auch einer Meinung sind dass viele
Unternehmen die Rahmenbedingungen so wie
es in Deutschland sind insbesondere im
Hinblick auf neue Technologien als
völlig unzureichend erachten
mittlerweile weil sie nichts tun und
sich hier hinzustellen und so zu tun als
gäbe es keine Probleme das finde ich
wirklich alle alle Achtung wert aber das
geht an der Sache völlig vorbei
möchten Sie Antworten nein dann gebe ich
jetzt das Wort an den Kollegen Wolfgang
Biele für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von 64
Milliarden auf 22 Milliarden die
corona-fieberkurve des gesundheitsetats
geht deutlich zurück aber erhöhte
Temperatur muss man beim Blick auf die
Zahlen immer noch feststellen während
andere Länder zur Normalität
zurückkehren
planen Sie Herr Minister Lauterbach
wieder über zwei Milliarden Euro für
neue impfstoffkäufe ein während
vorhandene Überbestände vom
Verfallsdatum bedroht werden
es ist ein Unterschied ob man dem
Angesicht neuartige Gesundheitsgefahren
das nötige tut oder ob man den Menschen
Angst macht um sich anschließend als der
große Retter in Szene setzen zu können
das habe ich Ihnen schon anlässlich der
Beratung des Haushalts 22 gesagt jetzt
sind wir ein halbes Jahr weiter ihre
Alarmmeldung wirken zunehmend hysterisch
und skurril Deutschland wird immer mehr
zum gesundheitspolitischen Geisterfahrer
eine konstante hat der
gesundheitshaushalt aber und diese
stückbäche ausgesprochen nachdenklich
die fatmaindustrie profitiert mit
zehnstelligen Beträgen nicht nur durch
die impfstoffbeschaffung sondern auch
durch ihre sogenannten
pandemiebereitschaftsverträge
natürlich kann man sich eine Welt sich
zurechtlegen in der uns große global
aufgestellte Konzerne vor den Gefahren
des Lebens immer besser bewahren die
technologische Machbarkeit trägt uns
durch diese Brille betrachtet in ein
leuchtendes neues Zeitalter
aber ist diese Art von
Fortschrittsglauben nicht völlig naiv
ist der drastische Anstieg von
Arztbesuchen wegen Impfnebenwirkungen
Zufall
ist das Auftauchen des neuartigen
plötzlichen erwachsenen-
ist das plötzliche Absinken der
Geburtenziffern in westlichen Ländern
Zufall oder versagt die Technologie in
vielen Fällen und Versagen die Regierung
und die meisten Medien im Umgang damit
was man in Zahlen klar messen kann sind
freilich die zweistelligen
Milliardengewinne bestimmter
Pharmaunternehmen so wie das Coronavirus
unerwartet über uns hereingebrochen ist
halte ich diese Gewinne für zu fahren
etwas anderes will ich niemandem
unterstellen
in der Logik der Politik dieser
Regierung müssten solche sogenannten
zufallsgewinne eigentlich abgeschöpft
werden
Notlage gibt es derzeit viele in denen
mehr Geld dringend gebraucht wird
die Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft
schlägt Alarm angesichts der Inflation
die diese Regierung mit ihrer Energie
und Sanktionspolitik schürt
gleichzeitig droht dass sich die Pflege
im Alter nur noch die leicht die Reichen
leisten können diese Regierung hat
nämlich völlig verschlafen die
Tarifanpassung beim Pflegepersonal dafür
vorzusorgen und nun gehen die
Eigenbeiträge der Betroffenen durch die
Decke
wir werden in den nächsten Wochen
diskutieren ob erhöhte Zuschüsse für
Krankenkassen und Pflege die angemessene
Reaktionen sind wir werden Fragen wie
die Versorgung durch Krankenhäuser auch
in der Fläche gesichert wird wir fragen
aber auch warum die reguläre
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit des Ministeriums
nun sieben statt fünf Millionen Euro
kosten soll
darauf ist Verlass die afd-fraktion
achtet jenseits der politischen
Fieberkurven immer darauf dass das Geld
das Gesundheitsministeriums für die
Dinge ausgegeben wird die die Leute in
unserem Land wirklich brauchen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Carsten klein spricht jetzt für die
FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja formal Herr
Minister werden die Mittel in ihrem
Haushalt 2023 sehr stark zurückgefahren
es liegt am in erster Linie sie haben
dasselbe angesprochen ja daran dass wir
die corona-ausgaben herauswachsen und
die wachsen aus zwei Gründen heraus auf
der einen Seite
beurteilen wir die Lage für 2023 so dass
sie nicht nötig sind aber ich sage auch
ganz bewusst dazu wir erwarten natürlich
auch nach so einer langen Zeit dass
viele Kosten die in der corona-zeit vom
Bund übernommen worden sind aber
eigentlich länderaufgaben sind im
Zweifel dann auch von den Ländern
endlich übernommen werden dass die
entsprechenden Strukturen vorhanden sind
dass die Länder reagiert haben ihre
Gesundheitsämter auf Vordermann gebracht
haben die Digitalisierung dort endlich
eingeführt haben alles länderaufgaben
die wir als Bund Kitten mussten und wo
ich davon ausgehen wenn 2023 ist noch
mal ernst wird die Länder dann auf
eigenen Füßen stehen können
die Ernst die Länder des ja meinen
konnte man dieses Jahr bei der Debatte
im April um die Verlängerung der
testverordnung sehen also ich weiß nicht
ob sie sich noch erinnern wir hatten
eine sehr intensive Debatte weil bisher
so dass ja die Tests die bürgertest die
eigentlich Aufgabe der Länder sind
komplett vom Bund übernommen worden sind
und dann gab es eine intensive Debatte
und viele Länder Gesundheitsminister vor
allem auch aus meinem Heimatland Bayern
waren die bürgertest unheimlich wichtig
dass die kostenlos weitergeführt werden
wir haben ja dann eigentlich einen
schönen Weg gefunden Herr Minister
nämlich dass es bei der Zuzahlung von
drei Euro eben weiterhin diese Tests
gibt und wo Wunder kein einziges
Bundesland hat danach die Tests die
kostenlosen Tests noch so wichtig
gefunden in der pandemiebekämpfung das
ist die drei Euro übernommen hätte und
ich glaube das ist beispielhaft wie die
Länder in dieser corona-krise Vorgehen
alles was vom Bund bezahlt wird alles
was kostenlos ist nimmt man mit aber
selber bringt man zu geringe Beiträge
und das ist nicht akzeptabel in einer
solchen Krisensituation
der Einzelplan des BNG wird ja schon
immer sehr stark die Mittel so stark
sehr stark gebunden von dem Zuschuss in
den Gesundheitsfond über die GKV auch
das ist eine intensive Diskussion der
Schätzerkreis ist ja zum Ergebnis
gekommen dass wir 2023 mit einem Defizit
von 17 Milliarden Euro noch rechnen
müssen dass wir füllen müssen das war
vor der Inflation das war auch vor der
Energiekrise also das wird mit
Sicherheit nicht weniger werden und
diese dieses Defizit wächst bis 2026
laut dieser Zahlen von damals sehr auf
30 Milliarden Euro an und jetzt haben
wir in der Diskussion einen Vorschlag
von innen Herr Minister wo wir den
Bundeszuschuss noch mal um 2 Milliarden
Euro erhöhenern auf 16,5 Milliarden Euro
und noch mal eine Milliarde Euro
Darlehen geben um diesen Defizit im
nächsten Jahr auszugleichen aber ich
glaube uns ist allen klar dass das
Konzept das jetzt vorliegt mit den
Nutzen der Reserven aus den
Krankenkassen nur Luftholen bedeuten
kann wir brauchen echte Strukturreform
wir brauchen Diskussionen der nächste
Strukturreform die müssen jetzt auch
angegangen werden und da erwarte ich
natürlich auch Lösungsvorschläge aus dem
Ministerium aber ich denke das sind auch
viele anderen betroffen denn der Weg
kann nicht sein am Ende dass dieses
Problem über noch einen höheren
Bundeszuschuss gelöst werden soll
Herr Minister sie haben die
Digitalisierung angesprochen von der wir
uns auch große kostenerlastungen
Entlastungen erwarten aber es geht auch
um die Frage zum Beispiel im
Krankenhausbereich um das Thema
krankenhausinvestition und auch da
findet ihr aktuell eine sehr intensive
und sehr spannende Debatte von Seiten
der Länder Gesundheitsminister statt ich
will einfach mal in Erinnerung rufen es
gibt schon seit längerem einen Bericht
des Bundesrechnungshofes der feststellt
dass die Länder über Jahre jährlich bis
zu 5 Milliarden Euro zu wenig in die
Krankenhäuser in dieses Land investieren
das führt natürlich zu einem schlechten
Stand bei der Digitalisierung das führt
zu schlechten Arbeitsabläufen weil wir
alte krankenhausstrukturen haben und es
führt ihm eben auch dazu dass wir keine
attraktiven Arbeitsbedingungen haben
Thema Fachkräftemangel es führt aber
auch dazu dass die Gebäude Substanz
schlecht ist und das fällt uns jetzt in
den aktuellen Krisen natürlich noch mal
auf die Füße veraltete Energiezentralen
schlechte Gebäudehüllen führen zu stark
steigenden Energiekosten und deshalb
habe ich vorhin noch mal erwähnter
Minister wie spannen diese aktuelle
Diskussion sind die gleichen Minister
die Länderminister die über Jahre zu
wenig für ihre Gesundheitssystem für
Ihre Aufgabenstellung getan haben melden
Sie sich jetzt pressemitialen mit großem
Getöse vor allem wir mein heimatminister
aus Bayern ja und schiebt dem Bund die
Verantwortung zu die Länder haben über
nicht schlafen deshalb kämpfen die
Krankenhäuser mit großen Defiziten im
Betriebsbereich und jetzt bei den
Energiekosten und ich erwarte dass die
Länder bereits sind dann auch dieses
Defizit zu decken statt immer nur an der
Tür des Bundesgesundheitsministers und
beim Bundeshaushalt anzuklopfen vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit Carsten
klein aus der FDP-Fraktion hat ein Thema
zum Schluss angesprochen was uns in den
kommenden Wochen noch beschäftigen wird
nämlich die
finanzbeziehung inzwischen Bund und
Ländern sie merken im Moment sind die
Haushälter dran in dieser Debatte über
den gesundheitsetats geht also um Pik
und ihre Aspekte dazu auch Gesine lötz
stellvertretende Vorsitzende
Linksfraktion endlich mal nicht in der
comedy-
aber leider hat in der Moderator nicht
die Frage nach der Erhöhung der
Krankenkassenbeiträge gestellt und da
sagen wir das ist eine dreiste Abzocke
das darf nicht passieren meine Damen und
Herren und sie selber haben Minister
Lauterbach wissen doch was die
Alternative ist zur Erhöhung der
Krankenkassenbeiträge seit 18 Jahren
mindestens reden sie darüber seit 18
Jahren sind sie in einer Arbeitsgruppe
der SPD zur Einführung der
Bürgerversicherung ich frage Sie wo
bleibt endlich wo sie jetzt Minister
sind diese Bürgerversicherung
und wenn sie sie werden jetzt sagen sie
sind koalitionstreu aber schauen sich an
was so alles nicht passiert ist was oder
passiert ist was nicht im
Koalitionsvertrag steht leider reicht
meine Zeit nicht um das alles
aufzuzählen meine Damen und Herren sie
könnten ja zumindest mal anfangen von
den
Ex-Kollegen der cdu/csu die mit
maskendeals Millionäre geworden sind das
Geld zurückzuholen das wäre ein erster
richtiger Schritt zweitens
sie haben angekündigt dass sie von der
Pharmaindustrie die in der Pandemie
traumgewinne gemacht haben sich Geld
zurückholen Sie zur Kasse bitten aber
auch da sind sie vor der FDP in die Knie
gegangen das darf nicht so weitergehen
meine Damen und Herren
richtig finde ich und das unterstützen
wir ausdrücklich dass sie einen ersten
Schritt zur Abschaffung der
Fallpauschalen unternommen haben die
Fallpauschalen waren von vornherein eine
falsche Entscheidung und dass sie jetzt
bei den Kinderkliniken Anfang ist er
richtige Schritt folgen muss die
generelle Abschaffung der Fallpauschalen
mein Name ist Herren
sie wissen doch selber wie die Situation
ist viele Ärztinnen und Ärzte müssen auf
profitorientiert in den Krankenhäusern
arbeiten sie leiden darunter es
widerspricht ihrer ihren berufsethors
und das dürfen wir nicht länger
hinnehmen meine Damen und Herren und
welche Auswirkung zum Beispiel diese
unsäglichen Fallpauschalen haben konnten
sie sich vor kurzem in der
ARD-Dokumentation wie viel Geld bringt
ein Frühchen anschauen die Krankenhäuser
bekommen von der Krankenkasse mehr Geld
für eine Frühgeburt als für eine normale
Geburt in Europa sinkt die Zahl der
Frühgeburten und in Deutschland steigt
sie und das ist doch Ergebnis der
Profitlogik damit werden die
Krankenhäuser erpresst das muss ein Ende
haben meine Damen und Herren
die Situation der Krankenhäuser ist
dramatisch wir alle sind von
Krankenhäusern in unseren Wahlkreisen
sicher angeschrieben worden und da hilft
es nicht jetzt anzukündigen mitten in
der Haushaltsdebatte irgendwann kommt da
etwas sie brauchen jetzt ein
Inflationsausgleich das Roulette das
Karussell mit den Ländern hilft nicht
weiter wir müssen die Krankenhäuser in
unserem Land stabilisieren und retten
und letzter Satz ich wiederhole wir
brauchen endlich eine solidarische
Bürgerversicherung packen Sie es an
danke schön
haushaltspolitische Sprecherin und
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende in
der Linksfraktion hier geht's weiter mit
Svenja Stadler die Mitglied im
parlamentarischen Begleitgremium 19
Pandemie ist und aus der SPD-Fraktion
kommt
[Applaus]
werte Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Gäste auf den
Tribünen und vor den Bildschirm
erst vor wenigen Monaten haben wir ja
den Haushalt für das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium
verabschiedet und es wurde an vielen
Stellen schon gesagt in der Höhe von 64
Milliarden Euro und ich finde diese
sieben diese 64 Milliarden Euro haben
einmal sehr deutlich auch gezeigt dass
die Bundesregierung in besonderen Lagen
und in dem Fall war es die corona-lage
bereit sind etwas zu investieren und
aufzufangen und zu unterstützen das
haben sie nicht nur damals gezeigt
sondern das zeigen sie in den vielen
Krisen die wir jetzt auch haben
und
ehrlich gesagt die Situation in
Deutschland hat sich durch Corona
verändert sie hat die Welt verändert und
es wurde auch noch mal sehr deutlich
gemacht wo wir ansetzen müssen was wir
verändern müssen vor allen Dingen auch
im Bereich der Gesundheit und ich bin
davon überzeugt dass wir das mit dieser
fortschrittskoalition mit der
Ampelkoalition auch hinbekommen denn wir
reden nicht sondern wir packen an setzen
um und mit dem Minister an der Spitze
geht das sehr gut sogar
und dann
ich finde das immer total spannend wenn
auf der von mir aus gesehen auf der
rechten Seite dann immer rumgenüllt wird
und geärgerte machen sie das sie hat
eine ganz lange Zeit es zu verändern sie
haben es nicht getan jetzt machen wir es
mit dem Regierungsentwurf 2013 ich komme
jetzt mal auf den Haushalt zu sprechen
und das wurde ja auch schon gesagt gibt
es eine Senkung von diesen 64 Milliarden
auf die 22,1 Milliarden Euro und wenn
wir uns auch da das Anschauen 2019 vor
Corona zu jetzt diesem Haushalt haben
wir eine Steigerung um 6,8 Milliarden
und das zeigt dass es uns wichtig ist
etwas zu verändern und diese
Herausforderungen die wir haben die
werden ja nicht weniger um Gottes Willen
und auch die Anstrengungen werden nicht
weniger weil wir wollen ja etwas
verändern mit aller Kraft und Macht und
vor diesem Hund Hintergrund ist es aber
wichtig dass wir sagen wir müssen mehr
handeln aber genau da wo es notwendig
ist und richtig ist mit mehr Qualität
und eben auch Effizienz und wenn man
sich dann den Gesundheitsbereich im
ganzen anguckt das ganze
Gesundheitssystem wie viel Geld da drin
steckt dann reden wir bei einem
dreistelligen Milliardenbereich und wenn
wir uns das Anschauen und das dass wir
ein modernes Gesundheitssystem haben
wollen dann bin ich davon überzeugt dass
wir das hinbekommen und und zwar nicht
zu also dass wir es hinbekommen ohne die
Patientinnen und Patienten zu belasten
und ohne auch wie es Personal zu
belasten wir bekommen das hin es gibt
andere Aktionäre bzw
Protagonisten die dann ein wenig leiden
werden wir müssen
Parallelstrukturen abschaffen und was
wir auch machen müssen ist dass wir es
gemeinsam abschaffen mit sämtlichen
Akteuren des Gesundheitswesen aber auch
mit den Bundesländern und auch natürlich
mit dem Bund und der Bund ist bereit
dazu seine seine sehr begrenzten
Finanzmittel zur Verfügung zu stellen
und auch der Verantwortung gerecht zu
werden und ich freue mich wenn alle
daran sich beteiligen der Minister hat
es angesprochen meine beiden
Koalitionäre haben es angesprochen die
Digitalisierung haben wir vor knapp 20
Jahren beschlossen und jetzt ist es
endlich Zeit nach 20 Jahren auch mit
dieser Digitalisierung die Erfolge
herbeizuführen auch im Gesundheitswesen
wir haben bisweilen drei Milliarden
bisher investiert und diese
Digitalisierung gibt Chancen zu
vereinfachen und sie auch tatsächlich
flexibler zu gestalten und zu
beschleunigen und dass das nicht nur
eine lustige fixe Zukunftsidee ist das
habe ich mir angucken können ich war ein
Schüttdorf Niedersachsen natürlich das
Beste Bundesland ever sage ich Ihnen und
dort ist es die Gesundheitsregion
Euregio die zeigt wie es funktioniert
wenn sämtliche Akteure aus dem gesimpfte
Gesundheitswesen zusammenstehen wenn
Krankenkassen dabei sind wenn
IT-Unternehmen zusammenstehen und auch
Juristen und da ist das Ehre Rezept und
auch die Ehepaar überhaupt gar keine
Zukunftsmusik mehr da wird es umgesetzt
und da wird daran gearbeitet
Herausforderungen anzunehmen und nicht
so kosten nein sondern wie schaffen wir
das gemeinsam und das ist dann auch der
Erfolgsschlüssel in dieser Region bei
diesem Protagonisten bei dieser
Gemeinschaft geht es nicht
gewinnmaximieren zu agieren sondern an
der Sache zur zu agieren und eben dem
Menschen im Mittelpunkt zu haben und
dann
sehe ich das bei uns auch so dass die
Wissenschaft einen erheblichen Beitrag
dazu geleistet hat dass wir gut durch
diese corona-krise gekommen sind und
jetzt heißt es aber auch die
Wissenschaft zu stärken und zwar
besonders in der Forschung es ist
wichtig effizient zu forschen und auf
deutsches Datenmaterial zurückzugreifen
und deswegen finde ich das sehr gut dass
der Minister am Wochenende nach Israel
fahren wird und sich gute Beispiele
holen kann und ein gutes Impulsgeber hat
wie wir es zukünftig auf sehr gute Beine
hier stellen können um die Wissenschaft
auch zu unterstützen eine effiziente
Medizin bedeutet
auch ein effizienten Umgang mit
Ressourcen zu haben ein funktionierendes
und gutes Gesundheitssystem stellt eine
gesellschaftliche Ressource da die ist
nachhaltig zu gestalten gibt und wissen
Sie hierzu müssen wir die Prävention
stärken und auch die Wissensvermittlung
da müssen wir auch investieren denn
viele Krankheiten sage ich ihnen
bräuchte ss werden es gar nicht
entstehen wenn die Willensbildung bzw
Aufklärung auch die Prävention gut
[Musik]
nicht nachhaltig auch gut funktioniert
dankeschön ich bin sehr dankbar und
deshalb bin ich sehr dankbar auch in dem
Fall dass wir
darüber gesprochen haben in Form von
gesundheitskiosken aber auch die
Digitalisierung in Form von Apps gibt es
viele Möglichkeiten denn dadurch gelingt
es uns eine zugangsbedingung zu
Präventionsprogramm zu schaffen und auch
zur Gesundheitsversorgung die alle
Menschen mitnimmt denn es gibt
unterschiedliche Menschen das wissen sie
selber mit den unterschiedlichsten
Voraussetzungen sie müssen alle
gleichzeitig die Möglichkeit haben
teilzuhaben an der gesundheitlichen
Versorgung und Prävention und der Fokus
muss auch in der Zukunft sehr viel
stärker auf dem sozialen Faktoren liegen
denn sie wissen selber unterschiedliche
soziale Hintergründe und ja auch
unterschiedliche Lebensweisen haben ein
erheblichen Einfluss auf die Gesundheit
des einzelnen Menschen das ist nichts
Neues aber jetzt heißt es dass diese
Erkenntnis die wir haben endlich auch
umzusetzen in Maßnahmen also was will
ich im Großen und Ganzen sagen wir haben
einen guten Regierungsentwurf bekommen
mit mit ja sie hüste klar sie kennen
auch keine guten regierungsentwürfe das
weiß ich aus dem Gesundheitsministerium
ich weiß dass ich habe nämlich jetzt
einen guten Entwurf und wir haben an der
einen an der anderen Stelle sicherlich
noch Möglichkeiten in ein Stückchen
besser zu machen mit Impulsen die wir
jetzt im Laufe der Zeit auch von unseren
Gesundheitspolitikern sicherlich
bekommen dann werden wir in die Beratung
gehen und am Ende werden wir den besten
Regierungsentwurf verabschieden nach
Corona vielen Dank
eine ziemlich optimistische Svenja
Stadler die unter anderem Mitglied im
parlamentarischen Begleitgremium covid
19 Pandemie ist im Deutschen Bundestag
nächster Redner ist Michael Henrich aus
der Unionsfraktion noch in der
Unionsfraktion muss man sagen und noch
im Bundestag im Frühjahr wird der
Ausscheiden aus dem Parlament und dann
zum einem pharmaverband wechseln
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir beraten
heute in einzelladen 15 und als wir im
letzten Jahr noch 64 Milliarden Euro im
gesundheitshaushalt eingestellt hatten
warten wir die Hoffnung dass wir im Jahr
2023 Entspannung haben und in der Tat
schlägt sich das in den
Haushaltszahlen nieder mit einem Etat
von 22
Milliarden Euro wir nähern uns Daten mit
schrittweise dem vor
corona-haushalt und ich bin Ihnen
dankbar Herr Minister
Lauterbach dass sie heute in ihrer Rede
anders als in der letzten
Haushaltsdebatte eine
gesundheitspolitische Agenda aufgezeigt
haben sie am vier Themen Punkte
angesprochen Pflege Krankenhaus
Digitalisierung und Kiosk und erlauben
Sie mir dass ich zu allen vier Punkten
ein kurzes Statement mache beim Thema
Pflege
ist das glaubt ganz ganz wichtig dass
wir in den Mittelpunkt stellen das Thema
Personal und da geht es nicht nur um
Bezahlung sondern da geht zum
Verlässlichkeit da geht es auch um
Entbürokratisierung dass wir in den
Mittelpunkt stellen die zu Pflegenden
die heute oftmals auf einem
Verschiebebahnhof sind zwischen
Krankenhaus und Pflegeeinrichtung und
pflegende
Angehörige beim Thema Krankenhaus ist es
glaube ganz ganz wichtig was Sie Herr
Klein angesprochen haben dass wir das
Thema dualistische Finanzierung wieder
stärker in den Mittelpunkt stellen und
auch etwas einfordern von den Ländern
das Thema
Digitalisierung da ist mein Wunsch und
mein Appell an Sie dass wir das auch als
Chance begreifen für den Standort kann
ich dann erinnern dass der ein berühmter
Professor im Bereich künstliche
Intelligenz Professor Schmidhuber vor
fünf Jahren mal in der FAZ einen Artikel
hat und gesagt hat wir haben die meisten
Daten in Deutschland wir haben
unglaublich viel Potenzial beim Thema KI
und ich bin froh dass im Haushalt 45
Millionen eingestellt sind aber
kommunizieren Sie das besser und geben
Sie entsprechende Signale an die
Gesundheitswirtschaft kritisch sehe ich
das Thema Kiosk des gebe ich ganz offen
zu weil ich denke dass wir genug Akteure
in der Versorgung haben der Kollege
Müller hat die Hausärzte angesprochen
wir haben Apotheker wir haben einen
unabhängige Patientenberatung wir haben
Pflegestützpunkte und ich glaube es ist
wichtiger dass wir die miteinander
verzahnen
und sehr geehrter Herr Minister
Lauterbach die wichtigste Frage haben
sie offengelassen wie
finanzieren wir das alles das ist heute
meine letzte Rede als
Gesundheitspolitiker nach 20 Jahren
und ich hatte jedes Jahr die Hoffnung
dass wir diese grundlegende Finanzreform
irgendwann hinbekommen und ich bin dem
Kollegen Müller dankbar dass er diese
Woche in der FAZ ein Namensartikel hatte
wo mal ganz wichtiger zentrale Themen
angesprochen hat wie geht es weiter mit
der Steuerfinanzierung wie bekommen wir
eine fairere Finanzierung der
Pauschbeträge bei den Arbeitslosengeld
2-empfängern ein Thema des eigentlich
diese Koalition versprochen hat aber
keine Niederschlag findet in diesem
Haushaltsentwurf und mein Wunsch und
mein Appell wäre gerade vor dem
Hintergrund lieber klein was sie sehr
deutlich gemacht haben dass wir eine
echte grundlegende
Strukturreform brauchen dass wir
vielleicht in dieser Legislatur
tatsächlich noch mal so zusammenfinden
wie das damals bei Lahnstein war
zwischen dem Herrn Seehofer und dem
Herrn Dressler als sie gemeinsamen komp
auf den Weg gebracht haben dass wir in
den schweren Zeiten in denen wir
momentan sind zumindest in dem Bereich
des Sozialversicherung den Menschen eine
Perspektive Klarheit geben das wäre mein
Wunsch den ich nach 20 Jahren habe ich
werde es nicht mehr erleben aber es wäre
schön wenn ich den den anthroposition
begleiten könnte herzlichen Dank ich
möchte die Gelegenheit nutzen mich bei
allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen ganz
herzlich zu bedanken für die gute
vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit ich
glaube wir hatten eine besondere
Atmosphäre im Gesundheitsausschuss und
es hat unser Arbeit geprägt ich möchte
mich bedanken bei vielen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern ob das
bei den Abgeordneten ist in den
Ausschüssen oder im Ministerium die ganz
besonders in den letzten Jahren
gefordert waren und wir Samstag sonntags
zweistündige Videokonferenzen hatten
fing bei denen die Arbeit erst an auch
ihnen herzliches Dankeschön ich fährt
dann andere Stelle im Gesundheitswesen
weiter haben arbeiten und würde mich
freuen wenn ich bei Ihnen ein offenes
Ohr finde herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit letzte Rede als
Gesundheitspolitiker aber hoffentlich
nicht die letzte Rede im Parlament
herzlichen Dank
michael henricher hat das selbst gesagt
wir hatten es eingangs auch schon
erwähnt wechselt im Februar zu einem
pharmaverband das heißt er wird jetzt
nicht mehr als Gesundheitspolitiker
reden aber auch noch nicht aus dem
Parlament Ausscheiden am Pult ist Saskia
Weishaupt aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen Obfrau im
Gesundheitsausschuss Ministerium stinkt
die Kürzung des itars von 64 Milliarden
Euro auf die 22 Milliarden Euro
erscheint im ersten Moment sehr
plausibel die kostenintensiveren
Ausgaben der letzten Jahre im Zuge der
corona-pandemie werden jetzt wesentlich
zielgerichteter ausgegeben sei es für
die impfstoffbeschaffung oder für die
Aufklärungskampagnen
uns ist allen klar die Pandemie ist
nicht vorbei und deswegen ist es gut
dass wir hier noch mal Geld in die Hand
nehmen
die gute Gesundheitsversorgung ist noch
wesentlich mehr gute
Gesundheitsversorgung gibt Sicherheit
Sicherheit dass wenn Pflege benötigt
wird sie auch wirklich da ist Sicherheit
dass wenn der Kinderwunsch ansteht man
die Frau auch eine Hebamme findet und
man sich keine Gedanken machen muss dass
niemand da ist und Ängste und Sorgen
nimmt und bei dieser sicherheit darf
nicht gespart werden
und ich weiß die haushälteren raufen
sich jetzt die Haare wenn wir als
fachpolitikerin hier unsere Wunschliste
Auspacken wofür wir alles Geld hätten
aber im Ernst eine gute und gerecht
finanzierte Gesundheitsversorgung ist
kein neues zu helfen und das ist nichts
was sie mal eben aus der Portokasse
bezahlen es ist ein Grundpfeiler unserer
Gesellschaft und wir wissen alle es gibt
wichtige Projekte die wir umsetzen
müssen und die kaum aufschiebbar sind
ich gehe mal in die Geburtshilfe zu den
Hebammen die Umsetzung des nationalen
gesundheitsziel Gesundheit rund um die
Geburt die eins zu eins Betreuung durch
Hebammen während der Geburt die Hebammen
geleiteten kreisele die wir ausbauen
wollen oder die Vergütung für
Angestellte Hebammen in den Kliniken die
die nach- und Vorsorge machen wollen und
ehrlich gesagt es ist nicht nur die
Geburtshilfe wir können auch weiter
schauen die Suchtprävention die NS
Stigmatisierung von psychischen
Erkrankungen aber auch die Entlastung
der reha- und mutter-kind-kliniken das
sind Punkte die alle finanzielle Mittel
brauchen
Gesundheit ist eine wichtige wichtige
Aufgabe und deshalb dürfen wir uns
selber nicht limitieren und es ist die
Aufgabe aller die hier Verantwortung
haben auch ernsthafte Lösungsvorschläge
zu machen wie wir das ganze finanzieren
können und gesellschaftliche
Herausforderungen begegnen können und
Lebensrealitäten von Menschen verbessern
können
und ja
wir leben in Krisenzeiten aber es ist
keine Option dass wir uns aus diesen
Krisen heraussparen und damit
maßgeblichen Kauf nehmen dass sich die
Gesundheitsversorgung hier in diesem
Land verschlechtert und für die Menschen
machen denn wenn wir ernsthaft daran
interessiert sind wenn wir ernsthaft
daran interessiert sind die
Gesundheitsversorgung auch zu verbessern
dann brauchen wir Geld und dann müssen
wir darüber nachdenken ob das ewige
sparen der richtige Weg ist oder ob wir
nicht die Schultern auch mehr belasten
können die auch mehr tragen können ich
bin froh dass wir am Anfang des
parlamentarischen Haushaltsverfahren
sind und unsere Aufgabe ist es jetzt
eben auch Handlungsspielräume zu
erkennen vielleicht auch Lücken zu
erkennen und diese auch zu nutzen das
erwarte ich von uns ein und ich freue
mich darauf vielen Dank
jetzt spricht Martin sichert für die FDP
für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
15 Euro bekommt jeder Arzt wenn er
paxlovit von Pfizer verschreibt 15 Euro
pro Verschreibung um die Gewinne eines
Pharmakonzerns zu steigern während
Millionen Menschen nicht mehr wissen wie
sie essen Strom oder Gas bezahlen sollen
die Prioritätensetzung dieser Regierung
ist völlig falsch
so wie sie mit der gasumlage
internationale Großkonzerne und deren
Aktionäre finanzieren genauso versorgen
sie in der Gesundheitspolitik die
Pharmakonzerne mit Milliarden Karl
Lauterbach präsentiert sich als
pfizerminister der deren Medikamente
ständig über seine Kanäle bewirbt
deutschland braucht endlich wieder eine
Gesundheitspolitik und keine
pharmapolitik
die Gesundheitspolitik besteht übrigens
nicht nur aus Corona wir haben zum
Beispiel einen massiven Mangel an
Pflegekräften und Fachärzten viele
Menschen müssen monatelang auf Termine
warten Monate die oftmals zwischen Leben
und Tod entscheiden diese Toten sind
Karl Lauterbach und der Bundesregierung
offensichtlich egal stattdessen kümmert
man sich lieber darum wie man wieder ab
Herbst mit dem Infektionsschutzgesetz
die Freiheitsrechte der Bürger
einschränken kann die Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes hat keine
wissenschaftliche Basis sie ist einfach
nur ein weiterer deutscher Sonderweg
diese ganzen Sonderwege die im Ausland
als politischer Extremismus Deutschlands
empfunden werden müssen endlich aufhören
weil sie nur Schaden anrichten kein
anderes relevantes Land steigt aus der
Atomkraft aus kein anderes relevantes
Land ist rein auf solaren Windenergie
kein anderes relevantes Land setzt auf
unbegrenzte Zuwanderung kein anderes
relevantes Land sanktioniert Rohstoffe
die für es selbst lebenswichtig sind
nahezu alle anderen Länder haben Corona
für beendet erklärt aber Deutschland
will nun die Maßnahmen noch mal
verschärfen wir die AFD vertreten bei
Corona wie auch in allen politischen
Bereichen das was in 90 Prozent der
Länder weltweit politischer Konsens ist
wir sind der Mainstream und die Politik
dieser Regierung ist extremistisch
und von der Union braucht dazu gar
niemand zu Grenzen denn sie haben mit
dieser Politik schließlich angefangen
deutliches Zeichen des Extremismus der
Regierung ist übrigens auch dass den
Abgeordneten wichtige Studienergebnisse
vorenthalten werden nur weil diese
Ergebnisse zeigen dass das
Infektionsschutzgesetz überflüssig ist
die Studien sind ja trotzdem
durchgesickert heute früh sie zeigen 95%
der Menschen haben Antikörper Corona ist
vorbei hören Sie auf die Menschen weiter
Zugängen
die Schäden der Maßnahmen müssen
schließlich die Bürger mit ihrem hart
verdienten Geld und mit ihrer kostbaren
Gesundheit bezahlen beenden wir die
Politik der deutschen Sonderwege und
kümmern wir uns endlich um die echten
Probleme im Gesundheitswesen das wäre
nicht nur besser für die Gesundheit der
Menschen sondern es wäre der auch
deutlich weniger Geld erfordern
jetzt das Wort für die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
war übrigens
pflegeunternehmerin vor ihrer Zeit im
Bundestag
frau Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bei manchen reden ist man ja
doch froh wenn sie zum Ende finden ich
möchte hier wieder zum Sachpolitik
zurückkehren mein Kollege der Karsten
klein der hat ja bereits erläutert
welche großen Themen und Bereiche im
Haushalt des Gesundheitsministeriums aus
liberaler Sicht besonders wichtig sind
und unser gesundheitspolitischer
Sprecher Andrew Uhlmann wird später auch
noch weitere nennen mir ist vor allem
wichtig dass wir auch die
Innovationskraft des Gesundheitssektors
immer mitdenken mit fördern und
essentielle Branchen nicht einschränken
denn darüber sind wir uns ja alle einig
unser Gesundheitssystem muss
zukunftsfest werden durch
Digitalisierung durch verwaltungsabbau
durch Innovationsförderung und dort wo
nötig auch durch Paradigmenwechsel
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Patientinnen und
Patienten und die dauerhaft an
demografische Herausforderungen
ausgerichtete Leistungsfähigkeit unseres
Systems die müssen im Mittelpunkt stehen
und da sind Vorsorge und Prävention auf
die klügere die günstigere und damit die